foreign
well hey what's going on yeah Jenny with
their ice blue hair It's Finally Friday
this is my favorite wig so yeah she's
looking fine too right now the [__]
figure is getting great
well all that training routine all that
not eating is helping too
lifting weights
I do eat just not very much just not
very much matter of fact earlier even
though Tom's birthday is technically
tomorrow we decided we were gonna do all
this stuff tonight so yeah we got to
work tomorrow so I picked up his cake
and we had a piece of cake yeah I got
that Publix cake got your presents yep
yeah the present I got was [__] um a
Sig Romeo seven
heavy duty Red Dot sight for uh my
rifles for AR-15s it's nice it's kind of
like something you you I'm looking at
I'm like man this is service Worthy
back in the 90s we'd have been impressed
with that
it's like an event it had been
futuristic in the 90s but it's a nice
[__] Red Dot
um especially for 200 bucks
it's built almost like a 600 500 uh
endpoint it's real heavy duty I saw the
tests on it and everything
takes double a batteries
60 000 hours of rent of life and it has
Shake awake
so that might as well be
a unlimited battery because soon as you
don't touch it for a few minutes it
turns off and then you pick the rifle up
Red Dot turns back on
it's a nice got anti-flash lands on it
and everything
yeah uh the might Bowser is wishing you
a happy birthday very much Jeffy Arts
wishing you a happy birthday Jeffy art
also says love Publix cake every single
cake I've gone through for any time it's
anyone's birthday like or any occasion
we always order a cake from there yeah
um they're actually reasonably priced
they're between 20 and 25 and that'll
feed probably like you know four or five
six people yeah and every single one
I've got cake I've got from there has
been phenomenal like here his favorite
one is like the strawberry and Peach
what is it called strawberry and Peach
sensation I think it's what's called
yeah because it's no frosting it's got
frosting on it no it's like frosting
it's cream yeah it's like whipped cream
yeah and then it has strawberries
peaches kiwi and grapes and grapes and
then it has slivered almonds like all
around the outside yeah and because it
doesn't have frosting it has whipped
cream on it instead it's like put on
there with like a like like a yeah it's
pretty yeah it looks like it looks like
uh there's a bunch of fruit it looks
like frosting but it isn't you could
that's the only cake I could eat I could
sit down and eat that whole cake
it's not real heavy and you don't feel
sick afterwards like I like
cake with frosting on it but usually man
after a slice I'm like oh I can't eat
any more of this that's too [__] rich
man it's like an icing sugar and [__]
butter with whatever kind of flavoring
[__] whipped into the dab yeah this
is what this one's kind of like more
like a summer style okay like it's much
lighter light and Airy and cool and
fresh fruit on it there's a lot of fruit
on it yeah nice all over the top they
let the damn cake and the fruit speak
for itself
reminds you like a big glorified Twinkie
[Laughter]
with the yellow cake with the [__]
cream filling I think for my birthday
last year I can't remember what I got
last year but I mean one year I got the
cannoli cake yeah and man that was
really good I might get that again this
year yeah well the thing is they have
another as far as the ones with like the
fruit on the top they used to have one
or the Publix where we used to live had
one that had that was like strawberry
and lemon yeah and it was a similar kind
of thing but a little bit different and
for some reason the Publix like down the
street from us here doesn't have that
one yeah so we got the strawberry and
Peach one instead and that one is just I
think I like the lemon one slightly
better but that's because I like lemons
like a little bit more than peaches but
it's still good but if I'm gonna pick
one I'm gonna get like something with
chocolate fashion has a good ideas in
the comment section he says we talked
about Flat Earth the other day can we
talk about fake dinosaurs me and Jay
talked about flaked dinosaurs one time
on the way to the castle
that's right remember that we passed the
[__] dinosaur park yeah and it's like
we started talking about fake dinosaurs
yeah
that's a trip too dinosaurs were plant
eaters human beings used to ride
dinosaurs yeah with all kinds of stuff
well the Creation Museum which I don't
know if still open where the [__] is
that Kansas Kentucky somewhere in the
midwest someplace and um they they have
or they did have I think it was a
Triceratops that had a saddle on it yeah
and I think it was like for photo
opportunities he could go in there and
ride and yeah because dinosaurs and
people uh side by side like lived at the
same time just like on The Flintstones
yeah who knew that that was a
documentary yeah but um well actually
when we were watching The Flat Earth
documentary one of the dudes on there
was also not only did he believe the
Earth was flat but he also believed that
dinosaurs were not real
yeah that that was also another
conspiracy I'm like yeah that dude had
some problems
[Laughter]
you know yeah just saying that's
that's all that's a whole other
conspiracy on top of a conspiracy
well they were always saying one of the
things that I remember they would say
well
dinosaurs didn't eat all the people
because they were actually mostly
herbivores even like Tyrannosaurus Rex
was a herbivore yeah you totally looked
like people were like well yeah but
those teeth that's a meat eater's teeth
and then they'll pull out fruit bats
fruit bats have teeth that have sharp
points on them too and that's just
eating fruit but it's real different
when you're a little bitty bat
you know what I mean and you're trying
to nibble nibble through the skin of
some kind of a [__] fruit yeah you
know what I mean you're gonna need some
sharp teeth you know they're not
grinding their food they're too little
so it's just it's just a bunch of
wishful thinking
you know dinosaurs were a long time ago
they were even
they weren't they were more like a bird
uh than they were they weren't reptiles
or most of them were somewhere I think
some of them were like a dimer Don was a
[__] reptile but most of them were
they were just well they were kind of
some of them were kind of in between you
know
yeah
in the way that like a certain line of
dinosaurs generally became Birds later
when you look at um
things like parrots and
blackbirds and stuff
the intelligence that they have they
have little bitty braids but they
[__] pack a lot of power it wouldn't
surprise me if those dinosaurs were far
more intelligent than we thought they we
think they are they're probably pretty
smart
yeah I would yeah because I kind of feel
like the miscon probably not so much
nowadays but I feel like the
misconception was like when we were kids
like in school that they were always
talking about how dumb the dinosaurs
were because they had little brains I'm
like but well that doesn't necessarily
mean anything it's not so much the size
of the brain it's like how many
connections are in there yeah
and some of them had two brains
basically they had a brain at the head
and had a little little brain to the
tail sorry I was thinking of Eddie
Izzard with a brain in the head and a
brain to the bomb what was that for they
had another one it's a brain and a tail
yeah and um so so the reflexes were
faster I think that was like stegosaurus
they had a brain did he have a butt
brain yeah butt brain well that was that
was because that was like that that was
one of his main weapons because it had
those big [__] spikes on it yeah
which I always thought was so cool I
always thought the stegosaurus was like
one of the coolest looking dinosaurs and
the thing about it is you can't just
across the board say oh dinosaurs were
dumb because there's like there was like
thousands and thousands of different
species yeah just like nowadays I don't
think they know them all they probably
haven't found them all oh I'm sure they
have them I mean like look how long ago
it was I mean it's it's amazing that
they know as much about them as they do
like as rare as it is to find fossils
and stuff yeah Trey says Jenny that blue
really suits your skin tone yeah thank
you I yeah I think that's probably why
this one's my favorite and honestly like
whenever I wear this particular one out
like I always get people being like oh
it's like I love all your wigs but it's
like that one just yeah she gets like an
upper level like get some more of those
of that color I have two like um of
exactly this because one of them got
like a little I mean the wigs if you
don't like hang them up and brush them
and [__] like that every time they get
like real [__] [__] up really quick
but so I have two of these and I should
probably get some more honestly I was
thinking about maybe I should just dye
my actual hair with this color that I
don't have to worry about it yeah but it
is like hard to maintain hard to
maintain you're doing it all the time
probably not as hard to maintain as the
red because it might not fade as quickly
yeah but you still gotta bleach it and
all that so yeah I have some bleach oh
yeah I mean I could get that yeah I have
some I've done it before I've had lots
of different I mean my real hair has
been lots of different colors I did I
bleached it white like blonde
um for a little while I didn't love it
um I had it bright red for a really long
time I had it purple
for a while yeah and um mostly I just
keep it black because it's just easier
and it goes with everything yeah for
those of you who don't believe it I I
used to have my hair blonde yeah it was
white white yeah I think I think when
you first met me I had blonde hair it
looked good everybody liked it um no I
think when I first met you it was black
but you but you bleached it not long
after that okay yeah I think yeah
looked all Airy and everything looked
cool
I mean yeah I liked it I think I don't
know I think I liked the dark hair
slightly better but I mean it both
looked good it's like I'm summer like
nervous really worried about it
Camp guy said owls started hooting a lot
last week I noticed that too when I went
out to
um get my car to go to work this morning
it was about 6 a.m and man the owls were
like hooting their asses off Oscar says
gonna need some content in that wig
matter of fact my screensaver is some
content in that wig on one of them have
I done have I done any in this wig yet
yeah I think so yeah yeah yeah
I did a solo scene and we did and we did
one together like a short one yeah I
have it somewhere I think it's like
eight minutes or something like that
oh but uh by the way guys I got I got a
fansley account
during the time we were trying to
[__] get trying to get into only fans
and having like a [__] of a time yeah
having a [__] I went ahead and [__]
I said well I'm gonna try to get into
fansley and I forgot all about fansley I
got a [__] notification that I got
accepted and I didn't even [__] apply
correctly
after I [__] applied and they wanted
me to do a video and holding the
freaking piece of paper say in my name I
didn't do that I didn't say the date so
I didn't do it perfectly yeah so that's
right I'm gonna get rejected no I came
back and gave it to me yeah so Jenny's
gonna get one of those too there's yeah
I got it all as popular as the only fans
yeah but I think it's like the second
most popular yeah because I think only
fans they were kind of getting in
trouble you know because you get to keep
more of the money they don't take as
much from you that's true
so I'm gonna keep my own account over
there I'm coming up with all kind of
ideas what I'm gonna do with that [__]
yeah we were talking about James
laughing her ass off I was coming up
with these [__] man he came up with
like the best idea and I was just kind
of like oh my God we totally have to do
that it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
[__] a solo leather daddy Channel bro
I'd berate you
[__] insult you about how small your
pecker is and I said Jenny we're gonna
have a [__] video where biker biker
was it biker bullies you in the men's
room you said mean biker bully mean
biker bully bullies you and Amanda we
got to get you going point of view
camera on your head because I got the
mounting for that for the action caps
and we'll sneak off one of these dead
malls and we'll go to the [__] Men's
Room in there and you [__] play the
other guy and I'm gonna go on there and
go hey what the [__] you doing standing
up at the urinal no no no no no no you
just sit the [__] down when I walk in
here you dare stand up around me [__]
like you and he was sitting down and
[__] out and then you know next thing
you go you know [__] he's blowing me
Jan
yeah but it's going to be POV see
so it'd be like fake gay I just can't I
just won't be able to talk because yeah
yeah yeah but it was gonna be like kind
of like comedy too everything everything
I kind of came up with was gonna be
funny
yeah but it was for the gay audience
though and just people that want a
[__] goof on it you know what I mean
but I thought it'd be funny I think it
would be funny because I had my I would
have my own channel yeah and then I'm
gonna start one too and then like if we
want if we wanted to post stuff together
like yeah tag one another how could we
just tag each other in yeah yeah so just
be like an ancillary account that I had
now another thing about fancies you can
go live
yeah oh so you can do that over there
too you can go live because I thought it
was just like only fans where you could
just well can you go live on only fans I
don't know maybe we never got it that's
right because it just got to to be too
much of a pain you're just [__] yeah
[__] off but we did get into stream 85
yeah we're in streaming we did get that
so we got that all sorted out the
problem we were having there was that
one I had forgotten to upload Tom's [__]
and uh so I finally did that and then
they didn't accept my first uh address
proof like I had to upload something
else like a bank statement or something
and then they let me in uh we got a
Super Chat thank you gadget3 happy
birthday Tambo I guess that's you
[Laughter]
yeah that's would that be funny
Zach says uh Jenny reminded me of a
story where someone brought a celebrity
pick to a stylist and The Stylist
interpreted the shadow behind the
celebrity as part of the hairstyle they
went home with a muffin in their head ah
I mean you would think
I've never heard of that
I could see that happening I mean but
you would think I would think if I cut
hair or anything which I don't because
nobody wants me touching their hair or
anything but um
I would think that you I would really
check like before I did anything like
are we sure this is what we want like
and then I would like make them talk it
out in words you know what I mean not
just the picture
um
Zach also asked did you listen to that
song I suggested for your video no I
haven't I haven't listened to it yet
okay look at country western song
wouldn't it oh Jesus was it I don't know
I gotta look at it again I got I got
distracted man I was busy at the time
were you really yeah yeah busy talking
to you oh oh that's what we were talking
about yeah that's what we were talking
about because he's like it's hilarious
because like he'll just like randomly
um message me
at work and I'm always kind of like
paranoid because [__] you know what he
you know what he did the other day is
that
he just randomly and I think I mentioned
this on the show on Wednesday night he
just kind of randomly just we were
talking about something else and then he
just randomly messaged me that he's like
oh when we do a scene like a werewolf
scene we have to like get a paw print
tattoo to put on your ass or something
like that yeah yeah and I was just kind
of like random but okay that's that's a
good idea and then it's not random I
know it's not but it's just it seemed
random to me yeah and then he sends me
like this little GIF of like a little
like werewolf porny like werewolf thing
and I'm just like um I'm in my office
and like other people are like right
there and so it's I'm always like
worried somebody's gonna see it yeah if
you see a girl with a [__] paw print
tattoo [__] uh I don't know if she's
gonna know it all but that means that
she's into bestiality
that's what that is uh I actually saw
some rapper chick with those and I was
going I bet you she doesn't know what
those mean
or maybe she does and maybe she does
yeah maybe she's into it she does yeah
that'd just be that'd be a funny tattoo
to have on your ass during a werewolf
[__] scene yeah yeah
as long as I just don't leave it there I
don't want anybody saying that I'd get
that yeah
[Laughter]
then I'll get like all kind of weird
messages yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[__] yeah that's um that's kind of
reminding me of that [__] but did we
talk about this on Wednesday where that
um that clip we were watching about the
about the glory hole thing what about
I didn't remember if we had like talked
about that like on a Wednesday night
show or not the that that CL that clip
you were showing oh yeah yeah okay now
what are you talking about yeah that was
a uh
it was a [__] um
not a custom made it was a [__]
amateur made
why am I talking about this there's an
amateur made video some dude in his
girlfriend made
in some kind of a
sex video arcade
and uh dudes are putting body parts
through these [__] holes
and you know he's filming her below the
dudes and he gets [__] um loses
control I guess I don't know what it is
and then every now and then he jumps
down there to [__] hell yeah and the
other dude doesn't know [__] I just
thought that [__] was hilarious
yeah I was just like
did he tell those dudes like later on or
did he just like let him think that it
was a chick the whole time and there was
like comments they knew they knew that
dude's name by by name oh and one of the
one of the videos because they were
there laughing yeah yeah that's what's
his name and he goes the dudes are his
friends
the whole thing's a setup of course you
know what I mean well I hope so because
that would be kind of [__] yeah
although like I said if you're just
sticking your sticking your opinion into
like random holes yeah then you're gonna
get what you deserve you're kind of
gonna get what yeah you put your [__]
[__] through a hole when somebody starts
sucking it that ain't a woman okay yeah
woman's gonna call the cops
they see some random dick poking out a
hole somewhere yeah they're probably
just [__] crazy all right they're not
gonna go over there and go oh what's
this but in the comments section they
were laughing they knew the dude's name
and somebody was like did his brother
did his buddies know that he was gonna
do that they were like no
I don't know if that's crossing a liner
well I guess it depends on what kind of
friends you got like maybe they're just
kind of like trying to consent for me
whatever his name is like that's just
[__] he does I would assume that they
signed a consent form
because I don't know if I would I don't
know if I did I'd be okay with something
it looked like from it was from the era
of [__] VHS yeah it looks old it was
old yeah like you know it's not old old
but it looked like not modern you're
right yeah and um
back then
probably harder to control what was
happening on VHS if you weren't selling
it and I have a feeling that that was
never sold that that was something he
made for himself
that ended up on the Internet yeah
yeah it could be because that seemed to
be their Kink you know yeah she was into
it the girls into it and he was into
like watching her blow other dudes yeah
yeah
it was it was uh and when you look at
the dude you'd never think that he that
it'd be the kind of dude that was into
that but you know well hardly anybody
yeah that you look at like yeah he was
tough looking looked like some [__]
Bruiser like I wouldn't want a tank with
the dude
but and his girlfriend was super pretty
but you look at a normal check just
normal yeah yeah
Zach says or you're the black dude in
Scary Movie who gets impaled through the
brain by a schlong that's right I
totally forgot about that [__] movie
I haven't seen that movie in so long
been so long
granther says it's only gay if you know
it's a dude yeah I guess so well yeah
because we were talking about that as I
was trying to work that out what would
happen
you know what I mean if I mean nothing
would happen it's just that some people
might you know what I mean like the
world wouldn't answer it comes to me you
know what I mean it goes [__] we're
gonna do this [__] scene up you know
[__] she's gonna blow you and I'm
like I'm looking at her going yeah okay
yeah and then [__] unbeknownst to my
stupid ass [__] you know every now
and then it's him going in there [__]
you know what I mean but then I would
think yeah I'd be like how'd you feel
like you'd have to go like you'd have to
go like yeah well I was kind of stupid
[__] what was I thinking you can't
see what's on the other side of the
[__] wall
yeah I mean you're really setting
yourself up setting yourself up yeah for
those kind of shoes yes you should have
known better you should have known there
was a catch
[Laughter]
now I will admit that it's pretty funny
it is pretty funny yeah I mean if
everybody involved is I mean this is
kind of like I said it's kind of it's
that was a great career section well
it's kind of it's kind of a gray area
because you know you don't want people
doing like [__] that you wouldn't
normally like consent to or whatever but
then again like these are all people
that have agreed to be in this
particular weird situation so
they're probably not that upset about it
I'd imagine yeah
[Laughter]
Oscar says Jen do a review for all the
VHS movies I already did that I thought
you were the one that asked me I already
did it I did a video over on scare salon
like a web and I watched all of them and
I reviewed all of them
thank you Jeffy art happy birthday Tom
thank you have a shot on me thank you
off to work but I'll catch you guys
later I'm gonna try to get loaded We're
not gonna go out tonight we're gonna
stay here yeah I mean we had a [__] ton
of bills and [__] all kinds of stuff
and I gotta buy a new motorcycle battery
on top of this other [__] yeah we kind
of you know and I did and I kind of you
know we bought a lot of clothes yeah I
spent a lot on your birthday present I
got hit 100 yeah I got a hit 130 on
[__] tag renewal for my motorcycles
yeah because it's my birthday it's your
birthday month your birthday present
[__] bam pay pay for your I
think of that every year like every
September when I get my tax review I'm
just like happy birthday me yeah
although I think I paid mine for like
two years so I don't think I have to pay
this year but I think
yeah I'm pretty sure I paid two years
last time so I don't think I have I
think I don't even I don't know I can't
keep track of [__] anymore
yeah the xb12 lightning bolt died
battery died had to come rescue me
and um
that lithium-ion battery died now I
hadn't been putting it on the computer
and recharging it but it's how old maybe
six seven years old
I've got a lot of use out of that it's a
shurai Lithium-Ion battery the
[__] are worth every penny
they're 200 bucks
but that thing lasted about six years
and a regular lead battery wouldn't last
that long
not with the abuse that I put it through
it lasted and it doesn't weigh anything
weighed three pounds
it was like a [__] 12 pound weight
savings over a little Harley battery I
mean you've had that for years yeah so
you can't beat you I could probably put
it on I've been put it on I've been
putting I got two of them the other
one's in the other bike
I've been putting it on the computer and
[__] relaxing the chemicals and
recharging and then relax and kept
trying to recondition it again and it it
holds a charge
but I'm not sure if the problem was an
old battery or if it's maybe my stator I
gotta [__] see how much voltage my
stator is putting out I gotta check that
voltage regulator
the [__]
thing is I just don't trust that battery
it's old now
yeah you know
um I'll probably just put a lead battery
on it and run it and then for Christmas
I'll get you a new ion battery okay yeah
yeah okay if you want sounds good yeah I
can do that I mean that's a while away
yeah that's a while away but I have time
to save up we're making all this damn
porn money I was reading an article and
I know this isn't going to happen to me
but I was reading an article in Business
Insider about this woman who she started
doing streamate when she was 40 and went
after the MILF market and
um she's married and everything like
that and her husband her husband is not
on with her but he's just like yeah girl
do it yeah so um so she started doing it
and what she does she streams four days
a week she says she starts at 8 30 in
the morning and stays on until she meets
her goal which is a thousand dollars a
day damn and um hard work so she does
Friday Saturday Sunday Monday so that
means she's not she's off the rest of
the time and she said her best month she
made eighty thousand dollars God damn
just by being on there forever yeah yeah
she would just like I said she goes on
um just like your standard like hot
blonde 40 year old okay good me and Jen
go on stream mating look at the
competition
and we see who's hitting and who isn't
and a lot of girls they're in there by
themselves so they don't and they don't
have any experience in
theater or streaming or you know you
don't know what their personalities are
like they just sit there sometimes on
their phone and [__]
other ones are working it their foot got
a whole character going and there and
and they're getting a lot of action and
and they're not good looking they're
just okay
and they're getting the money because
they're yeah most of them are not like
they're fun beautiful or hot or I mean
some of them are not not gonna lie but
remember that one girl it was just
gorgeous yeah there are some really
really beautiful just sitting there
doing nothing and she was kind of she's
a fit she was a fitness chick you could
tell she was lifted dark hair and
everything
and she wasn't saying anything I was
like I wouldn't give her any money
somebody eventually gave her money and
went with and did a little she did a
little thing I guess
but the girls who were constantly busy
were kind of just average looking girls
that were
dressed cool and really work on the
crowd I'm like interacted with everybody
well because like like I said and I even
get like on my lunch hour and stuff like
that like I'll scroll through some of
the people that are live like at
whatever time and see just what they're
doing and I'm just like like if I was a
dude who was gonna pay for this
um you know who would I so I would click
on random people and like 95 of them are
just like sitting there doing nothing
yeah which I was like well if I'm gonna
click in here I don't you know there's
nothing that would make me like stay
there because they're not like
interacting it's like fishing with the
camera or anything it's like fishing for
dudes that are trying to jerk off
ain't that something well yeah that's
exactly that's something
and like I said you would you know
there's a lot of competition people are
just going to be like popping in and out
of your room like if they click on you
so it's like you have to be like
entertaining like all the time to get
people to like stick around I would
think and uh some couples do well uh but
from what I've heard the couples that do
well aren't just doing
basically sexual stuff they're just
entertaining in there yeah we'll be
doing kind of what we do here right it's
just there's different angles to it you
know they're drinking games and stuff
and
you know oh [__] we should do that we
should do that they do all kinds of [__]
on there we should do like drinking game
type stuff and the guys Gotta Be You see
the thing is is that
the the guy
in in the team
can't has to be careful he's not he's
not really to be intimidating or scaring
off the [__] male customers you're
trying to [__] be like the carnival
marker calling guys in well you're good
at that though so it's yeah I just I'm
just gonna use the sales Tech techniques
that I used you know like when we would
go to the conventions I'd [__] sell
all of Jenny's books I just start
[__] grabbing people you know who
Jenny Ashford is you don't this is Jenny
Ashford right here you know just started
introducing them and [__] then
Jenny would [__] do you want to uh
I'll tell you what the book's only 10.99
I'm going to take a picture with him
right now and because you guys can
[__] go and then you'll have free the
picture for your Facebook oh it sounds
good autograph copy fine okay another
five dollars whatever and [__]
just suck them into the sale you know
what I mean [__] but they got they
had a good time the whole thing was in
it uh yeah we didn't make them do
anything that we want to do I mean they
stopped and looked at this yes and then
we'd entertain them and talk and get to
get to know him and uh sell them a book
and [__] entertain them for 5 10 20
minutes however long they wanted to be
entertained and then they'd walk off and
they would grab another one
yeah it's just like that sounds good at
that I'm real good at it yeah which I'm
not good at so it's a good thing that
he's good at I'm real aggressive with
that yeah so it's gonna be fun they're
just gonna we just need a new gig you
know and we want to be able to continue
this show because we like doing this
show yeah and uh in order for us to
continue working we got to start pulling
more money and we got to pay bills
around here yeah you know what I mean
like most like like everyone yeah Leslie
says nice pendant Jenny very fancy thank
you I actually got this on Sheehan I
think it was two dollars maybe not even
two dollars maybe it was a dollar sixty
or something we will plug the [__] out
it's just plastic Sheen's got great
clothes for women
not so much for men but for women great
clothes and they're cheap and they're
good quality
you have to wait a little bit about a
week but when they show up they show up
I mean everything we've ordered and
we've made like a lot of orders when
they are since then I think everything
is coming a week yeah so if you order it
and then like a week later it arrives we
probably spent about 250 300 maybe on
Xi'an total huh something like well man
well maybe a little bit more than that a
little bit more now and and really if if
we were buying at a retail place if it
was like a Hot Topic like back in the
day it had been several thousand dollars
worth of [__] as much clothes as I got
much closer I got basically racks I
basically got a whole entire wardrobe a
whole whole roller drove for about three
400. I haven't even worn all of it yet
okay she hasn't worn this she just got
this show that that was only like uh 14
bucks wasn't it something like that 1450
it's it's Black Velvet
like I got velvet I got so many dresses
like I said I haven't even like had time
to wear them all yeah
it's a black velvet baby doll dress yeah
see it's like that and it's like a horse
City kind of front and back up so they
can see the whole shape of it go over
here
that's it
yeah yeah but that's a cute [__]
dress
yeah like it's super comfy too yeah and
like I said I was thinking that it was
going to be like wish and all the stuff
was gonna make be made of like newsprint
or something like that but all of the
stuff that we've gotten has been like
really good no good quality yeah like
really thick material
it's not cheap [__] they got like [__]
like [__] tan combat boots and
military style stuff but I'm looking at
it I'm going uh that doesn't
no I wouldn't buy that you know what I
mean the men's stuff isn't that good
good thing I'm a lady
um let's see uh Zach says yeah Alan
Arkin died oh that sucks well he was
he's old he was older yeah time for him
to go but I mean he was a great he's a
great actor he's gone into The Nether
world of the force man he joined the
pleuroma
John Smith says apropos of nothing just
watched the bay damn that's some nasty
[__] that was a great [__] movie
whenever anybody asks me like what the
BET what some of the best like found
footage even though technically it's
mockumentary but that's kind of like a
sub genre of found footage that's always
one of the ones that I recommend that's
a great [__] movie and I feel like a
lot of people don't um talk about it but
it's good if you like found footage
watch the bay it's really good it's
mockumentary like I said
and it's nasty it's real nasty which one
that was about you didn't see it okay I
saw it but I really like it like if you
say hi everybody hi pookie say hi
everybody
[Laughter]
no she's been social all day she's
always social in your face she waits for
Jenny by the door she knows when Jenny's
coming home yeah about a half an hour
before I get home she goes and sits by
the parks by the front door and like
yeah and just looks at the door waiting
for you to walk in Waiting For Mama yeah
I was like oh my God that's so cute yeah
like Thomas sent me a picture of liquor
it's so funny yeah yeah grafter says
I've read that most dudes that do gay
porn aren't actually gay it's just
another shoot yeah yeah they're not yeah
I don't know the percentages but yeah I
mean you know uh gay porn I guess
there's like uh it's better for men in
the porn industry they make more money
doing gay porn than they do straight
porn women don't buy porn no all right
so why would we we buy erotica yeah like
written erotica pretty much only men do
their real visual
well you're top-notch male performers
want to make money well that's not as
straightforward no all right that's I
don't want to insult dudes that are in
straight porn that's second and third
run [__] well they just don't make as
much because they're not the big they're
not the draw right
and they're also just lower on a totem
pole in terms of looks all your real
good looking dudes who are super jacked
and [__] that are in porn are in gay
porn
yeah overwhelmingly straight guys that's
where the money is and what they do is
you say well how could a straight guy
have sex with porn technology
they use something called trimix
which is a mixture of three things one
of them is Viagra and the other one's
the other two are something else and
it's a liquid and you inject it directly
into your dick
and they'll use it in surgery too if
they have to do surgery on a dick a dick
surgery [__] you will rock up within a
few minutes and you'll be totally rocked
up for [__] 12 hours no matter where
you want to or not there's just no way
that sounds a little inconvenient yeah
and once they're on that [__] they'll do
anything you know they can do anything
even if they're not into it and they
won't lose an erection
uh problem with trimix
uh talking to the guys in the industry
that I know like like [__] bill
it's habit forming
uh what ends up happening is
guys are like you know what I got a hard
on but it's not as hard as it was when I
was on trimex
and then he starts thinking that way and
all of a sudden he can't maintain an
erection because it's not as good as it
was before so it's like a psychology
so they just say [__] it I'm gonna go
try a mix and then the next thing you
know
they can only get it up a try next
so they kind of get psychologically
dependent on it
yeah I feel like that kind of happens
yeah anything like that
so because you feel bulletproof when
you're on that nothing can stand in your
way yeah well shoot yeah [__] the car
yeah I'll [__] a car bring a car in here
oh yeah yeah [__] a 700 pound check
bring her in here man I'll do it I'll do
anything I can do anything right now so
they kind of get dependent on that
yeah
and then they're also talking about uh
Julian Sands yeah they did find uh those
remains in the mountains and that was
indeed Julian's hands that's what
everyone thought that it was because oh
yeah yeah they found him he got lost and
he died he got lost and died I guess I
mean that's what they but yeah that
sucks man I always like Julian Sands he
was in Warlock and
uh he was in um Arachnophobia which is a
great [__] movie what was he he was
on a hiking trip or something yeah
like he hiked in that area like pretty
frequently as far as I'm aware but I
guess he I don't know if he got lost or
he got like or disoriented or something
but he was missing for a while and
everybody just
they they pretty much knew that he well
what killed him exposure I'm guessing he
didn't have his equipment with him I
don't know hmm
I'm weird
I haven't read that much about it but I
did see the article that said that they
had identified you can't kill me by
doing that I just spent too much time
out there you just keep walking in a
straight in this in a straight line
until you find a road or a river well
like I said I don't know what happened I
don't know if he got attacked by an
animal or I don't really know yeah some
something more to it than that camp I
said famous movies with coin operated
xxx live strip shows maybe Taxi Driver
all I can think of off the top of my
head uh there was recently a horror
movie called revealer which was pretty
much entirely set in a strip show booth
um which was actually pretty decent if
you want to see it it was like pretty
low budget but I think it was on shutter
but I really liked it
uh the the might Bowser who that's David
Jane by the way uh says my fat ass will
run an only fans he wants to see a tub
of lard lay on the moves and get dissed
I don't know some people might want to
see that you never know well see that's
the thing that's one of the things
that's really enlightening about
scrolling through
streammate because like I said we we
usually look at that because that's you
know the platform we're going to be
using
so we like to just see I said I don't
want to like call it the competition but
we want to see like what other people
are doing on there and the thing about
it is that there is a mind-boggling
array of different looking people
there's young people there's very very
old women there's hugely hugely fat
people there's just like and everybody
it seems like everybody's getting some
play like obviously some people do
better than others but interestingly the
top
because we were kind of looking it's
like who's the top people like that are
that are live right now like whatever
time it is and it's not necessarily who
you would think like yeah some of the
girls are like young and hot but not as
many of them as you might think they
were when you go on especially on a
weekday
and you look who the top performers are
who are live at any one time
it's going to be cougars women in their
40s that seems to be the overwhelming
yeah it seems like older women yeah is
really like they range from smoking hot
to fairly hot to okay they raise you
like that and then underneath them will
be the younger ones
yeah the younger ones are underneath
them like 20s 18 24
but uh a lot of times they're jumping on
the Cougars there's a lot of you know
ass
they're they're [__] dudes that are
just young guys like cougars and also I
think it has to just do with the fact
that
middle-aged guys like cougars so I think
just the
the odds are a cougar is going to be
popular they have broad appeals yeah
they're statistically
likely to have a good fan base
because a cougar is harder to get in a
way
most women after 40 don't look that good
if you see one after 40 she looks good
she's kind of like stands out
so there's kind of an element of power
there I like cougars I'll take a cougar
over a young girl
um
I think most guys are like that
now will they marry him I don't know
it's they're not really Mary the guy the
guys that are in this game
are not looking for wives they're
looking for
release all right and then a cougar is
like
that's the way to go they got experience
you know yeah and I think the guys that
are looking for the younger ones
are kind of more getting off on the fact
that they're older than that girl
and that maybe they're wiser and that
they're kind of like
above them in a certain way you know I
mean they're a little bit higher I think
there is an element of that so well the
thing is is that that's good because
what it is is it's bringing out it's
bringing out like protective instincts
let me treat you know let me take care
of you you know you need some you need
help that's not that's not the deal with
the cougar
the cougar is more of a peer
peer-to-peer relationship
you know what I mean or or somebody
who's above you if you're a guy in your
20s and you're looking at this [__]
hot cougar and me and Jen knows cougars
[__] Sonia could go to the club and
pull [__] 19 year old guy she was 43
44. yeah and she'd just take a late guy
in his late teens he's not even older to
drink she just had him like putty yeah
yeah she was real good at that
yeah and it's you know and that was and
you know fine she
she's not looking to get married either
she says this is just fun sex
yeah I mean back then she's there yeah
back then she's not like that now but uh
she's went back with her husband
but that was just like uh
ego boosting to an older woman if you
ask me that she can beat out all these
young girls
in the eyes of a 19 year old dude
I mean I the youngest I well I dated a
guy that was 11 years younger than me
yeah at the time yeah
um I remember that yeah
and I've had dudes like real young dudes
hit on me too yeah like at the club and
stuff recently yeah recently yeah I'll
go to the bathroom I come back and I
watch some dude [__] chatting her up
and I pause and watching I'm watching it
from a clock across the [__]
bar [__] I was grinning I was like
what's what's she gonna do
and I saw Dewey dude was being cool if
he wasn't cool I would [__] jumped in
there and stocked it he was actually
yeah the one I'm thinking of the most
recent one he was very nice because you
have to watch you never know like
because a lot of dudes you never exactly
know how you can't be mean
um because you never know if they're
gonna like [__] go off on you you
just don't know what kind of dude that
is but that this dude was like actually
very nice yeah you know being a guy you
know [__] you can see a young guy in
his 20s you can see him going through
the motions you're like yeah yeah I've
been there done that I know what you do
it dude okay okay now you you're getting
up your nerve I see you instead of
watching the whole [__] problem no I
mean he was really nice yeah and I liked
that yeah you know when I was just kind
of like because he was like want me to
buy to buy me a drink and stuff but I
already had a drink and I was with
somebody and everything like that so I
was just kind of like I was like no
that's okay and I was and I was really
nice too which I wouldn't be if you were
an [__] if you were an [__] I'll
just be a [__] ran out of the gate yeah
but um but he was actually very and he
was really cool about it he was just
like ah you know I don't think he knew I
don't think he knew I was there no he
didn't because like I said I think you
were in the bathroom yeah I don't think
he knew I existed I don't think that he
saw you before because most of the time
like most of the time you're there and
it's very clear yeah that but you know
sometimes if somebody just wanders in
and you're like in the bathroom or out
of the bathroom patio or something like
that like you do get
people are approaching and like I said I
don't mind a people approach as long as
they're cool and as long as if I say no
I don't want to like do what you fight
over it yeah then just be respectful and
be like oh well that's okay you know
what I mean because like I said I won't
be an [__] unless you come at me like
being an [__] yeah then I'll be a
total [__] me and Jen's already talked
about this [__] long time long time
ago when that [__] happens I like it
I actually kind of get a boost out of it
because then all of a sudden I'm well
first of all it's good for your woman to
get hit on by a good guy because that
makes her feel better
all right
and uh it kind of makes me feel better
that you're with a woman that's being
desired by other guys if nobody wants
her then what the [__] you want her for
yeah man and then when she says no you
know that you know that's kind of a
confirmation that you could trust her
yeah so you know
I never get mad at it if it's a cool
dude I get mad when it's a dude it
doesn't know the [__] he's doing and
it's obviously [__] violating well
yes
I'm gonna have to beat your ass
like you grab her ass and [__] I grab
you by your [__] throat that didn't
even say nothing to me he was just like
he didn't look at me and then say that
he just like walked by and did that it
was like really did you really was on
that [__] like snake on [__] had
him by the [__] throat he's trying to
get away from me
I was on Trend at the time and [__]
what exactly did you think that was
going to accomplish I mean I guess he
didn't really think about it even his
friends wouldn't defend him
well that well that's when defense that
actually kind of Cheers me up because
it's like at least his friends were like
wow yeah don't do that I said if I see
him again I'm gonna kill him
yeah yeah
uh the might Bowser who like I said I'm
pretty sure is David June um I love
y'all but there's no way I can watch
y'all's only fans it would be like
watching my friends naked you're a
little curious but you feel like you're
violating privacy I get that in some
ways but I don't know I guess we've been
in so many situations and I'm just like
yeah whatever yeah I mean the the the
the only fans well okay no the stream
mate thing really wasn't oriented
towards 13 o'clock it's not the swing
you guys over there that'll be a
different [__] scene over there
probably I mean if you guys want to come
right but if you guys want to come you
can't we're not shy of that
no I'm not sure here's another thing is
that stream mate is not like ChatterBait
where you're in public doing this
[__] weird [__] and anybody can see
it that's not like that on stream mate
it's like this if somebody wants if you
can't you can
do topless but you can't you can show
boobs but that's about it
anything other than that has to go
private and that person has to pay for
that yeah
so yeah so everybody else wouldn't see
it it would just speak yeah a few
minutes so you can't just randomly like
wander into our room and like see all
kind of like crazy [__] yeah it's not
like that like you might see tits I
think you can show tits yeah I have to
like look again at like what the
regulations are because we did see one
woman that was like that had like
sucking on dildos yeah I think you can
do that so I guess you can do that yeah
yeah but you can't like you can't do
anything like below the belt you can't
do so there's no like below the belt
nudity but you can show titties I guess
you can like suck on dildos you can do
that kind of stuff but you can't do like
anything other than that unless people
pay and like and then you have to go
private and only people that pay can see
it yeah and it's like depending on what
the rates are it's just like 4.99
anywhere from 299 to 6.99 a minute
now there's another way to do it is you
can do what's called a gold show which
is a private show anybody who pays in
gets to watch it and you set how much
gold is it like 200 gold 500 gold
um
we'll get about a little bit more than
half of that I think it's 65 65 I think
one gold or equals one dollar and you
set a time limit you know like okay
Show's gonna start and that [__] fit
half hour
uh it'll start when we hit 400 gold
and then um this is what's going to be
in the show and it's like stipulates
we're going to do this this and this and
this during the show other people will
start coming in if you don't mate if we
don't meet the goals we can either start
the show
even though it didn't meet the goal or
we can say we can kill the show and you
get your money back yeah
and that's a gold show and it also
stimulates how long it will also be
stipulated how long the show will be
and they're at least a half hour
you really want to show Pride to be an
hour or so
and and you're going to have a bunch of
different [__] you're going to do in the
show
a lot of it's just entertainment stuff
okay we're gonna do this do this and
this and then just enter and then you
can interact and tip during the show
yeah
then there's another thing you can do is
you can go cam to cam but we probably
won't have that feature we don't want to
see anybody yeah I don't really want to
do that it's just like that kind of
wears me out if we're gonna have Cam to
cab it's gonna be expensive I mean I
might yeah it's like I might get to a
point where I'd be okay with that but we
were talking about it earlier because I
said to him I was like I kind of like
the idea of like doing the stream like
that and just like I know that it's
actual people watching you but it's like
it I kind of like abstract it yeah so
it's like that's much easier to do when
you're not seeing them right in your
face yeah when it's like an actual
person you know what I mean so it's like
I might get to a point where I'm
comfortable with that but we'll see how
that goes we'll we'll take it the show
will definitely be us and it will be
humorous
it will be here yeah I mean I don't
really plan on super like pretending to
be somebody I'm not because I'm not good
at that anyway yeah but it's gonna be
fun
yeah like I said I'm looking forward to
it John Smith asks what's on your shirt
it's hard to see that's your obscura
Undead shirt yeah that's uh some that's
our friend Sherry Mouse
that's her like radio show thing that's
her little yeah it's her YouTube channel
her YouTube channel obscura Honda she
hasn't been working on it recently
though she handed it off to some friends
she hasn't been feeling well I've been
talking to her actually I talked to her
today
what's the matter with her I've seen I'm
trying to get down to the bottom of it
she said I haven't seen her since all
social media she's not feeling well
she's had some kind of thing going on
with her life I don't know if she's
DJing a show though in um a month or so
because I did a poster we need it I
think we need to hang out with her yeah
I mean she's in Tampa but Mouse is um
probably the only
black female goth that we know that is a
and she's a famous DJ
cute wears like new [__] New Orleans
kind of Mardi Gras goth outfits mixed
with everything you never know how she's
going to be dressed but she's uh
she married this other guy I don't know
if they're still married I think it
might that might have something to do
with that oh maybe I remember them
getting married I remember that yeah
married a goth white guy from the scene
I think he was a DJ or a musician wasn't
he something yeah yeah yeah yeah I
didn't really know him that well yeah
man I got really behind
Ben says chubby chasing is real it is
yeah
yeah I mean a lot oh yeah well hey Zach
sorry I got super behind on like oh yeah
what well you were talking and I didn't
want to like interrupt so what's that
say uh Zach says thank you very much by
the way speaking of I hate in movies
when they get real pretty actors for
realistic stories like an indie drama
about a McDonald's cashier but it's
Angelina Jolie
then they have to like ugly him up I'm
like why don't you just get like a real
regular looking person to like put them
in the [__] uh Oscar says love them
cougars yeah we know you do yeah yeah
um we've been camping camp with Oscar
and his girlfriend
oh he did yeah yeah yeah yeah his
girlfriend's however it's hot it's all
right
let's go camp the cat but you're hot
well like I said yeah she was crying
over you dude [__] she's like I hope
he comes back but he came back I think
he came back
are we are we allowed to like say that
kind of stuff on there yeah I don't know
what's been going on you've been talking
to him I haven't yeah this so they're
good but okay okay
[__]
uh Tammy said oh wait a minute
where are they talking about this oh
okay so yeah they were talking about
um Julian Sands and then Camp guy said
we had a dude on the next Road over for
Mars that died when his four-wheeler
turned over on top of him and he
couldn't get it off he smothered to
death yeah it happens the coroner can
see scratch marks holy [__] I remember
that like show I shouldn't be alive and
it was like this guy that just like
rolled over on his [__] legs like he
lived but his legs up for life it's
crushed his legs did he have to have him
amputated no it's just that they were
all I mean I mean they're all [__] up
I don't think he could walk after her
because they were and he was under there
for like three days it was like a day
and a half two days something like that
it was some crazy yeah and it was
because it was like out in the middle of
[__] Alaskan Wilderness or some [__]
like that I was like I can't imagine and
then like he almost got eaten by coyotes
and [__] too I'm just like oh my God no
thank you
um and then Tammy said I worked with a
girl
whose six-year-old died when a four
wheeler rolled over on him with him on
it oh [__]
God I can't [__] imagine that is
horrifying horrifying
um
yeah Camp guy said a friend who's Big
Brother almost died when he had a car
wreck the car landed on top of him and
he was smothering luckily the paramedics
got there just in time
I said they told him they pulled cars
off the top of dead folks all the time
ugh
it said I think about it all the time
like I said because
you know now that I have to commute so
far for work so it's like I have to you
know drive two hours every day like an
hour there and an hour back so I'm
always like really really aware of like
holy [__] like
at any moment
I've only ever been in one accident
knock wood or whatever I'm not
superstitious but I'm just saying
and it was very very minor and it's like
it wasn't even I was on my way to work
it was probably back in 2015 I want to
say and I was on my way to work I worked
in Longwood
um which was only about eight miles from
where we lived in Sanford
and I was going into the turn lane there
was an SUV in front of me and I guess
whoever was in front of the SUV
for whatever reason because the light
was green
um and then the turn arrow was green but
for whatever reason the person in front
of the SUV like stopped suddenly like
they just hit the brakes like that and
so the SUV stopped suddenly and I didn't
have time to stop so I plowed right into
the back of the SUV
um luckily for me the SUV was not
damaged at all my car was [__] up uh
like the whole front end it was a Nissan
uh what the hell car was it Nissan
Sentra I can't remember what kind of car
it was but it was it was a Nissan it was
white and so the whole front end
crunched in
um the airbags deployed uh and
everything but all that happened to the
SUV guy in front of me was his coffee
spilled all over
all over the cabin like of his car but
he was like cool about it because I was
like dude there was no way I could stop
um because it was just like the light
was green I don't know why the person in
front of it because I couldn't see like
around the SUV so I couldn't see that
the car in front had stopped so I just
like plowed right into them I shouldn't
have been following so close I know it's
kind of my fault but the thing about it
is that the cops came and they were just
like man it really seemed like just an
accident like I didn't get blamed and my
insurance didn't get go up or nothing
like that because it's just like it
seemed like it was nobody's fault it was
unavoidable so
I mean you know in the insurance paid
for everything and happily
I was not injured although I didn't
realize how the car was old
um I think it was a 2002 or 2003 or
something like that and like I said this
was in 2015 I'm pretty sure
I didn't realize that when the airbags
deploy
um which is good that it did
but it fills your whole entire car with
this horrible smelling
powder stuff
so it's like for a while like it's it's
just like bursts in the car and like I
couldn't see anything because the whole
the whole cat inside of the car was like
filled with like this white powder [__]
and it like smelled really bad and I was
just kind of like holy [__] yeah Victor
Garcia's in there saying yeah well
McDonald's has some hot guys working in
a something 50. Now You're Gonna Save
the [__] McDonald's turned you gay
well he already said gay porn turned me
again
and McDonald's
it's those french fries man anybody
would go gay for those french fries they
soaked they soaked them in [__] sugar
water and then they [__] cooked them
that's what my brother told me because
my brother well I don't know if that's
true anymore but it's like my well they
don't cook them in beef Tallow anymore I
don't think
um because vegetarians complained but um
well see the thing is sugar water bro
I'm pretty sure they soaked them in
sugar water before they freeze them
that's what my brother told me my
brother works for McDonald's for a long
time yeah no that's that's a known fact
yeah
yeah when I was used to cut [__]
potatoes make french fries and [__]
soak them in salt water and then
sometimes the chefs would be like hey
man put put three cups of sugar in that
yeah I was like really yeah he hadn't
been big old [__] barrels
mix them up and then when we cook them
and we had them cut as more like potato
log kind of like uh you know like the
big fries the big healthy fries they
came out they tasted just like a [__]
McDonald's french fries like oh man
that's good because that's that Sugar
you know I think that's what it is yeah
sugar makes everything better yeah sugar
and salt but yeah sugar
I was it's really weird I was reading
because there's like a food blog that I
read sometimes
and I was reading an article on there
that kind of made me feel like I've
isolated and alone in the world but um
it was kind of it was talking about how
how shitty steak fries were and I'm like
wrong sir wrong steak fries are the best
fries yeah sorry you just have to cook
them right I mean I well I think that
was the that was the thing that they
were complaining about it's like oh
they're such [__] because nobody
ever Cooks them right and they're always
like too mushy look it's like french
fries are good I don't care if they're
mushy or crispy or whatever I actually
prefer them slightly more on the mushy
side as long as they're kind of crispy
on the outside we used to batter them I
mean McDonald's fries are epic I'm not
saying that but I used to like and out
of this was a long time ago but I used
to like that KFC did those potato wedges
that still have the skin on yeah holy
[__] those were good I really like those
we used to batter fries
you know that yeah you're running
through some batter Checkers did that
for I don't know if they still do it but
Checkers used to do that run them
through some batter and the batter was
just like regular
regular kind of like egg wash and and
then you would throw them through flour
and the flower had been seasoned with
with uh [__] zatarans [__] cages
yeah yeah yeah Checkers did that and
then you [__] throw them in the
[__] Fry Basket when they come out
they'll have a slight crust on them
within man they're good like I said I
don't know I haven't been to Checkers in
a long time but um
but where I every now and then I used to
get a Checkers because they had a
walk-up in Daytona and they had battered
fries and they had two different they
had like kind of plain and then they had
ones that were like kind of spicy you
know what I mean they always got like
the plain ones but yeah they were really
good they were like really interesting
questions and [__] I know I'm like super
behind I'm so sorry that I got like this
behind uh yeah always wear a seat belt
yeah I always do y'all need to bust them
drinks open man come on it's Friday
oh yeah McDonald's has some hot dudes
working so now okay
um
yeah Ben said because more people will
go see a movie with Angelina Jolie than
starring some random 7-Eleven clerk yeah
a [__] a friend of mine used to [__]
make a point out of [__] picking up
hot black girls that [__] who worked
at McDonald's
that was like their Kink yeah it was
just that [__] he always says because
he liked it he says
I get all my black girlfriends at
McDonald's
okay because yeah they got cute little
black girls at McDonald's just to drive
through
huh yeah it was a long time ago I mean I
never really noticed because it's like
you're usually driving when we go
through the McDonald's I don't really
see what they look like yeah his name is
Joey Joey Mills the biker guy I used to
know this is years back though
Zach says KFC KFC still does those the
um the potato wedges I guess had them
within the last year myself anyway huh
I've been to KFC in a really long time
so I don't know uh and Victor said
Popeye's fries are battered
I didn't know that I don't think I have
gotten we went to Popeye's like probably
like a year and a half ago but I don't
think I got any friends John Robertson
said Jenny do you have any good book
suggestions that have old-fashioned
witchcraft it's one of my favorite
subgenres of horror I love the book set
back in the 1600s and 1700s ooh I can't
think of anything
off hand
but I will look into it and see if I
have anything that I've read anything
and I'll get back to you because I can't
think of anything because usually I've
read some stuff about witchcraft like
lately but it was always like modern day
you know what I mean
um Camp guys said McDonald's owns the
land for just about every store they
have franchises too if one of the owners
doesn't run the place the way they like
they will shut them down uh McDonald's
is really in the real estate and french
fry business not the hamburger business
I mean and I'm gonna say
McDonald's as much as they're disparaged
I don't think they're disparaged as much
anymore as they used to be no they're
good
um yeah it's like they actually do have
some decent food it's not as cheap as it
used to be like no fast food is I guess
but I mean most of the [__] they have
there is is pretty good McDonald's is a
[__] miracle of [__] mass
production and and and sanitation
in general McDonald's are clean uh and
[__] the way the kitchens are run
it's like a robot working it working it
back there it's hard to [__] up this
system they're very very organized and
they keep control of everything done
with a single slice of cheese I mean
their inventory is [__] fantastic
um
what is fantastic what is what is so
strange is being a [__] a cook myself
is
is the unbelievable consistency of
McDonald's no matter where you are it
tastes the [__] same pretty much yeah
that's the selling point you go to
McDonald's you know exactly what it's
going to taste like yeah here's the
downside of McDonald's
McDonald's has somehow come to represent
American food overseas that's not
American food
American food is not really like that
that's just McDonald's it has its own
flavor yeah and it's good you know it
tastes good I love it especially when
you're drunk when you're drunk it's
great the Big Mac's good and it doesn't
taste like a hamburger it tastes like a
Big Mac
yeah surprise because we make hamburgers
at home all the time they don't taste
anything right now
it's just uh it's kind of like a
glorified
vending machine that's what McDonald's
is yeah
but you know exactly what it's going to
taste like it's like when you buy a
Snickers bar you know what it tastes
like there are times where I'm going I'm
going like look man I'm hungry
um I want to make uh what's a good way
to put it I'm hungry I want a hamburger
okay well I'll go get a hamburger it
won't be McDonald's
I'll get a hamburger maybe five guys
yeah or Red Robin yeah but yeah
sometimes I'm like I want a McDonald's I
don't want to [__] up because that's
its own thing it's its own thing
yeah I want some I want a Big Mac and I
want those [__] fries
there's been times where I said I want a
Whopper and I want those onion rings but
man [__] big [__] Burger King is
really kind of sucky it's Hit or Miss
yes well and the one that is that we
usually end up going to because it's on
the way to various places like we would
usually stop at it because it was the
most convenient place like on the way to
the movie theater like from where we
used to live and it's kind of it's a
shitty location I'm actually surprised
it's still open yeah because it's like
super hard to get into and it's like
really they they redid it and stuff but
it seems like they don't have enough
employees and it's like all this there's
hard there's like one person working in
there yeah and they're and they're just
kind of like I'm just trying to work the
window and they can't work the front
desk at the same time and it's like
sometimes the food is okay and sometimes
not so much so I don't know it's like
like I said it's really inconsistent but
I don't know I never liked Burger King
as much as McDonald's anyway and
honestly I like Wendy's better than both
of them yeah but we don't really have a
Wendy's that's like convenient you know
and Wendy's tasted like Wendy's it
didn't taste like McDonald's
you're not going to get that there yeah
I like to win I think I liked Wendy's
because they had baked potatoes which I
was a big fan of and I'm in a salad bar
a lot and they had a salad but they
don't anymore but they used to have a
salad bar
um and the frosties of course yeah those
were good and they're burgers and
chicken sandwiches were actually good
but I haven't been to a Wendy's in
probably like two years so I don't know
if they're any good if you get the
double burger and the triple remember
yeah that's right yeah yeah I'm not sure
like I was watching a thing the other
day about
their um the value menus and like which
ones had the best one and everything but
it's just kind of like
I don't know we don't eat at a lot of
fast food places so I don't really know
like what all the offerings are the only
thing they're not cheap anymore well not
really well no because because some
place like I don't know about um I think
Wendy still has like the five dollar
box meal or just like but you have to
get like a set thing it's just like a
junior Cheeseburger
um nuggets a drink and small fries and
it's like five bucks or something like
that so all of them do have
like these cheap menus there's usually
like a couple only things that you can
pick from you know what I mean but still
I mean if you only have five dollars
it's like an old school Southerner there
he makes his own potato wedges who said
that yeah yeah that's David yeah yeah
I'll tell you what though uh when you
talk about
old school Southern stuff
if you ask me [__] Popeyes
hard to beat Popeyes Popeye's Chicken
man I wish they still have the shrimp po
boy they had the bet they had the best
[__] they don't happen they had the
best red beans and rice ever
we'll still do according to everybody
everybody and now they have like the
best chicken sandwich everybody has lost
their [__] [__] over that chicken
sandwich that came out
I think that I think that chicken
sandwich like single-handedly like
[__] upped their profits that year
whenever it came out and then everybody
like all the other fast food places were
like oh [__] we need to like up our
chicken sandwich game too Kentucky Fried
Chicken [__] kind of lost its Mojo
uh you don't see them around much
anymore they used to have another one uh
called churches when I was a kid yeah
that's still around churches was pretty
good but then it started to get greasier
and greasier and I've never been to one
the problem with church is from the last
the last time I went to a church is I
walked in there and the place was
[__] filthy like all the tables were
dirty and [__] and I was like [__]
churches uh churches I I don't know if
they even exist anymore I think they're
still around but um
I'm not real sure I remember there being
one in Daytona but I don't I'm pretty
sure I never ate there
where we used to eat like we used to get
KFC sometimes because like I said when I
was growing up my dad
um managed one managed to KFC yeah so a
lot of times like we would get chicken
you know what I mean and my uncle like
owned a franchise like in the area so we
would always get chicken like for family
get-togethers and stuff however
uh probably about a mile from my
grandmother's house where I grew up
there was a local place called Hamptons
and they had fried chicken burgers and
footlong hot dogs and man that [__] was
delicious I don't know if the place is
there anymore it's probably not but
because it's been there since like
[__] 1906 or whatever it was like a
really really old school like Diner kind
of place the Fried Chicken was like kind
of greasy but in a way that was like
really delicious and those foot long hot
dogs were [__] amazing they put them
on they were like real
um a little bit not burned but they were
like a little bit like crunchy like
crispy on the outside and they put them
on crunchy like a big slab of like
crunchy garlic bread that was like a
foot long with like butter and [__] on
it and man those were good see if you
Southerners remember [__] wards
I remember that remember Wards yeah
Mississippi's field Awards
an award Awards was kind of like the
dollar store of Mississippi wherever
there wasn't any food they'd build
Awards there you know like in the middle
of a dam
food what do you call it food not a food
Oasis what they called a food desert
food desert yeah yeah they have Awards
and they were around since I was a
little kid
and it was a burger joint
the burgers were pretty good but they
weren't great they were just they were
they tasted kind of homemade in a way
but one of the Ward's Burger I used to
get was a [__] habit with chili on it
remember that yeah and then they put
lettuce I would never have got that yeah
[Laughter]
the french fries were okay and then
they'd had shakes and [__]
but it was just real
real ghetto real [__] redneck
Southern yeah or sometimes that's what
you want yeah that's what you wanted
yeah
and it was like
both it was a place where [__] black
Southerners and white Southerners
[__] went and ate together and [__]
Awards
or they all agreed that that [__] was
[__] Southern as [__] it's kind of
like how Captain D's is now yeah
you're gonna have [__] rednecks and
foot I don't know if they have Captain
D's anywhere other than the South do
they yeah it's a chain it's a chain it's
a fast food chain it's a fast food
Seafood chain yeah that is very good you
get a lot for your money and it's it's
deep fried deep fried fish shrimp shrimp
Hush Puppies they got Fried Green
Tomatoes yeah uh french fries yeah they
got all that uh stuffed stuffed crab yep
iced tea sweet tea everything is like
super super easy yeah yeah and it's
usually everything usually usually all
black staff even the sweet tea is
probably deep fried
all black staff kind of older black
women running it up front like you black
your black Aunt all right and they're
[__] sweet as [__] and [__]
they're they're cooked with pride that
last time that last one went to a couple
months back we need to go back to
[__] Captain D's yeah the food's
always good there
it's a lot you get all you get a lot
it's like more than I can yeah and then
like uh you look across the way and it'd
be like [__] a table of 10 and
they're all [__] black people in
suits [__] dresses because they came
back from church it's it's just like
yeah they hit it after it's just like
old school Southern [__] like I said
it's a chain but it's tradition here
yeah yeah
it's technically it's fast food yeah I
mean they have a drive-through yeah but
we would always eat for rednecks and
[__] though that's fancy though it is
fancy because you get inside of the
table and they give you the big things
of uh yeah [__] yeah sour cream and
it's not kind of like
some other restaurants because it's been
around for a long time
and it has like a biracial clientele and
it's Southern as [__]
the people that work there always take a
lot of pride in the [__] cooking I'm
a cook I know I can see I can listen to
that [__] kitchen back there there's
all these [__] black dudes [__]
and they were that kitchen was [__]
banging because they're running the
drive-through in the front and [__]
every all the food that's coming out
there was good
yeah like and I was just like yeah this
[__] here was cooked with pride because
they're cooking for our people
they're cooking for our people you know
yeah yeah it's like a cult some fried
catfish yeah yeah yeah Fried Green
Tomatoes yeah hush puppies and yeah
french fries it's a big [__] platter
fried green tomatoes and for you
Europeans who are listening to us a
tomato you can ripen a tomato and eat it
if it's green you can't eat it unless
you cook it
if you batter it and roll it in [__]
seasoned cornmeal and deep fry it it's a
delicacy it's good yeah they're real
good real good
yeah I feel I feel like that's kind of a
did do they do Fried Green Tomatoes
anywhere else or any kind of like green
tomatoes alongside okra fried goat deep
fried okra [__] no well you deep fry
anything it's gonna be good I mean
pretty much because I'm not a big fan of
okra otherwise
um but I mean deep fried the [__] is
good and I've had some people disagree
with me
but as far as I know it I'm my [__]
culinary history is pretty good
deep fat frying with batter and cornmeal
is an African thing that's in the south
and uh I've had some guy say no no they
fried in Europe too yeah they fried but
I don't know if they battered and used
cornmeal and corn flour maybe I'd have
to look it up yeah sure some of the
things that they're using like okra
that's an African
vegetable as far as the Southern Culture
goes
southern food in general is Africanized
food
um it has a strong African influence in
it
Southern Culture if you if you go back
and study
African-American historians Thomas Soul
he'll tell you that African or Southern
Culture and African-American culture
is the same culture and really it goes
back to like the wildlands of Ireland
and Scotland
because
you have to understand what it was like
back in the slave days
you had a lot of free black people with
with [__] white people living side by
side as subsistence farmers
um it's a good movie you should see it's
called the free state of Jones and I'm
from Jones County uh my dad's side of
the family
and um
this is long before segregation and
everything there was a lot of cross
cultural and cross-racial breeding
between
free blacks and poor whites all right
during that time
and
are languages merged and our Cuisine and
the cultures kind of merged
and Southern Culture is Black Culture
and black culture is Southern Culture
it's it's the same culture just being
expressed by two different people
although as
white Southerners became
more gentrified they became more English
in ways uh there's Thomas Soul explained
it he's got whole videos on it
motherfucker's a genius and he's Tracked
Down
Source material and Witnesses of the day
of of those days foreign Witnesses who
were in who were impartial you know
witnesses to what was going on and
they'll tell you all kinds of stuff
about Southern Culture very fascinating
very fascinating
white Bowser said churches is here in
Indiana Oh is it they're awesome yeah
they're dirty but they're dirty yeah uh
and James Knapp said there's a Church's
Chicken in Kansas City like I said I'm
pretty sure well there was one in
Sanford not that far from our house I
don't know if it's still there or not it
was over by where that Starbucks and the
mattress place was
you remember where that was on what the
[__] was that road I can't remember the
name of that road was but yeah it was
there was a churches up there
I think it started out as a
Bojangles yeah and then the Bojangles
closed and then church is open yeah
Bojangles moved them around they moved
to a better location I don't think I've
ever eaten Bojangles is good now that
I've yeah there's a lot of fast food
places that I haven't eaten at Bojangles
was good what I had there was
um pulled barbecued pulled pork sliders
all right on uh like dinner rolls and it
was real good had pickles and [__] and
hot sauce uh we
the thing is is that like we said before
the fast food is is getting good it's
got real good quality well it had to it
had to but the prop but the prices went
way up it's not cheap yeah for the
amount of money you spend they said like
Bojangles [__] I could go to [__] uh
I could go to [__] Fifth Element
Indian restaurant and eat all these as
much as you want yeah or I could go to
[__] koiwan [__] Chinese
restaurant for [__] 12 bucks and eat
all the [__] shrimp I could stuff
myself with and I'm a protein type
[__] where I gotta have a lot of
shrimp well that's a shrimp all the
steak you get all the pepper steak you
want you don't have sliced steak there
he's getting Peppers you can eat all the
peanut chicken yeah yeah so I just Gorge
myself on [__] protein you can eat
all the squid you want it's good yep see
all the crab you want so
the the corporate chains even though
they're just banging they get a lot of
business they're not really the best
deal right now best deals in all these
buffets Indian and Chinese buffets they
[__] give you they'll feed you we're
a big fan of the buffets yeah well it's
funny because
um the guy at work was asking me to
recommend some restaurants in the
Orlando area because I guess he's coming
here
and I would go to memories of India that
was the first one I recommended I was
like I don't know if you're into Indian
food or not but that's my that's not
technically it's not Orlando it's Lake
Mary but you know what I was like
outside of Orlando and I was like that's
my favorite restaurant in this area
um and yeah I told them about Corey Juan
I told them about that place that we
went to in Mount Dora for my birthday
last year that British pub yeah yeah the
British the magic the magical meat boots
yeah it was good yeah
yeah so it was like a classic British
but it was owned by British people like
a British couple owned it but um I have
to go back there actually
because that was really good I'm trying
to think of like what other places I
recommended I think I recommended Fifth
Element
which is like an Indian buffet you like
they have like a normal menu too you can
order off the menu also but then they
have like a small Buffet it's not like
koiwan where it's like a massive Buffet
but um they have like a small buff it's
probably like a dozen dishes maybe 15 20
dishes something like that and um and
they're always really good too
but
um yeah I'm trying to think
we don't really like I said if we find a
place we like we usually just end up
going there like all the time so we
don't really like try out a bunch of
different stuff as much as we kind of I
was like last week I was like man I want
to like find a good Thai place
you know that's close by
but we just never get around to it we'll
probably end up going to koiwan again
tomorrow
we did find a closer
Chinese buffet
to our house
um it's actually
I think it was actually eight miles away
rather than koi won which is like 20
something well 18 miles I think it's 18
miles from our house or 24 miles I don't
remember I looked it up
the hilarious thing is that during the
week so we went to this place I don't
even remember what it's called but it
was like another Chinese buffet and it
was a lot closer so I was like well
that's good that we have that option but
we went and ate there and I was like
well it's good but it's not anywhere
near good as uh koiwan or like or
Ichiban which was with the other one
that we went to which is still kind of
far but was also pretty good
I was like well you know if we
absolutely have to have Chinese buffet
stuff and we don't feel like driving all
the way there at least this is close by
so I'm like at work the other day I
don't remember what day it was it was
like Tuesday or Wednesday and I get a
test
I get a text from Tom and he said I was
I was telling them about the um because
you know that that other Chinese buffet
yeah yeah any sense to be attacked I'm
at work and he just randomly sends me
this text he said I'm cheating on you
with that cheap Chinese chick
is what the text said and I just like
busted up laughing and I was like I'm
immediately there I was like oh you're
at that and he's like yeah he's like
actually it's better when it's busy
because when we went there it was like
there was hardly anybody there and like
the food was okay but it was like kind
of cold like a lot of it was kind of
cold they did have egg foo young though
which koiwan doesn't have we can go to
that tomorrow if you want
well it's your birthday so you pick you
can pick anywhere you want to go we'll
go check the price on me really yeah
it's your birthday I just want to eat a
bunch of shrimp well yeah I mean yeah we
can do that anywhere but you know yeah
if you want to go to koiwan we can go to
stick we didn't go to it's fun I think
the only thing about koi one is this
farther
it is kind of fire Ichiban Ichiban
didn't have steak either but the food
was better
yeah maybe we'll do each bomb
although each bomb was only five miles
closer wasn't it it wasn't that much
closer yeah it was it was like literally
four miles closer
because the only thing that's cool about
Ichiban is that it's right across the
parking lot from a books a million
that's true but see that might be bad
too because every time I go on books a
million I'm gonna spend like a lot more
money and I don't really have a lot of
money because every time I go in there
I'm like oh look at all this you know
what I mean I think like last time I
went in there I didn't do too bad I
bought two books and they were in the
The Bargain thing so I think I only when
I when I bought a chocolate bar too so I
think I only like paid I only like spent
like 15 in there but still man it's
talking about Red Lobster yeah we like
Red Lobster I actually like Red Lobster
but you know what it's um
oh God I gotta say behind somebody was
asking me before about uh I think I
mentioned on the Wednesday night show
about how they taught clogging in school
and he said we had to do square dancing
we did square dancing too actually we
did square dancing every year in
elementary school and maybe junior high
like for PE and I remember like the
girls would always be kind of like we
weren't like into square dancing per se
but we were always like oh we're gonna
the boys are gonna dance with us and
stuff and the boys were like kill us now
like the boys like did it because you
know it was still they were still the
girls are have cooties fees so we we
liked the square dancing but the boys
did not but yeah we we did square
dancing it's cool too pretty much like
every year I think every year of
elementary school we did square dancing
and the boys always looked like they
wanted to [__] die it was hilarious
um but yeah so uh so a lot I guess
churches is still a thing because a lot
of people are talking about it okay yeah
John Robertson said yeah Tom we have
Church's Chicken here but it's it's in
the bad side of town that's where it was
in Daytona too yeah
um but it's the best in town my
great-grandmother raised me and she
cooked the best fried chicken okay she
was 89 when she passed oh I remember
liking it it's just the last time like I
said I don't think I don't think I've
ever eaten there it's um uh not that I
unless I was a little kid
it's not like KFC
it's not like Popeyes either it's just
its own thing it's more kind of like a
homemade tasting Fried Chicken so it had
a at least that's what it used to be
Mike Bowser says Captain D's is in
Indiana too once when my daughter was
like seven I asked what she wanted for
dinner and she said I know a little
place called Captain D's yeah
raising her right yeah I mean Indiana is
kind of
is that that's not considered South
that's that's Midwest Midwest yeah I
just wasn't sure I wasn't sure like with
the reach of Captain D's was because I
don't really hear anybody talking about
it it's a southern thing but it just
grew yeah like I'm sure they have
locations like other probably exactly
the same too we described it accurately
then then you got it and that's what it
is
the way we described is that the way it
is there I mean maybe he said she acted
like it was an exclusive restaurant that
needed a secret knock yeah yes this
little place called Captain D's without
realizing it's oh that's so cute though
they're seven they don't know I used to
be really into
um when I was a kid because I was like a
total Seafood [__] still am
um I used to be really into Arthur
treachers now I don't even know if
Arthur Treacher's is still around sounds
familiar I know that there used to be
one there was one for a long time in the
Orlando Airport but it was like a fast
food place that was along with like a w
root beer or something
because I remember eating there last
time I was at the airport which is
probably like 10 years ago but um Arthur
Treacher's in Daytona like probably like
two miles from where I grew up there
used to be one and it used to be like
this big sit-down restaurant right and
it was right next to gooding's the
supermarket that we always went to and I
would always like we never went because
you know we were kind of broke so we
didn't like go out to eat any any time
usually
um but you know every now and then we'd
order a pizza or get like crystals or
something but we didn't like usually go
to restaurants but whenever we did we
always went to that Arthur retreaters
and it was like this huge oh my God it
was like this big thing like you get it
was kind of like a better
um
Long John Silver's it was like a classy
or Long John Silver's like it had like
all the booths with like green leather
on them and I guess it was supposed to
be kind of like a British pub but I
didn't know that at the time because it
was all dressed up next to me that
compared to me I'm gonna go get my damn
vest my new vest oh you feel
underdressed yeah I'm underdressed now I
got a new vest I look like a damn Star
Trek villain from [__] the old Star
Trek I mean you already look like a Star
Trek yeah
[Laughter]
like y'all's gonna make me hungry why is
it always kind of food
we didn't talk about grits man I've had
grits in a long time
I've been like I said I've been trying
to
lose some weight because you know
because of this new Endeavor that we're
doing
so uh pretty much the only way I can
lose weight is just like by not eating
um I've you know I'm 50 something years
old it's like
I'm I'm pretty uh I don't love it but
this is pretty much the only way that it
works I have to go severe calorie
restriction so what do you all think it
is
yeah look at that [__] I like it I like
it I want my porn outfit that's your
porn outfit
look like something on them down Star
Trek I like it though I like it it's got
fur on it yeah it's very fashionable
yeah that's kicking yeah that's kick ass
we're gonna do a whole the whole thing
with that maybe I'll wear this with my
with my werewolf outfit
yeah we're thinking about somewhere I
look okay [__] dog head I looked on
Xi'an right yeah and I looked at like
werewolf they don't have any werewolf
stuff no I had to make it wearable so
I'm yeah I'm just thinking if I'm gonna
do what I'm picturing
I might have to make it myself see
here's the thing I want it to be
if we're gonna do a word I'm still I'm
I'm still vacillating between
sexy werewolf or lady Predator because I
kind of maybe want to do lady Predator
too good good which one will be harder
probably lady Predator would be harder
but um
I kind of want to do because look I'm
looking to like pictures of like sexy
werewolf all this other kind of stuff
and it's like most of them are just like
sexy lady with like some fuzzy ears on
them like that's lame yeah I was like I
want to do I want to look like a
werewolf I want to do the whole fate
like the muzzle and everything
you know what I'm saying I want to look
like a [__] dog I want to have a dog
head but it'd be like hot still
is that weird the my uh the might blower
scene I look like a [__] white face
Klingon yeah Tom the merciless and [__]
okay is um
is uh granter's hammer is he uh is is he
uh still in the chat is she still I
don't know I haven't seen in a while
like but um I saw him earlier said
grafters if you're there man go ahead
and [__] um
drop some in the comment section so I
know you're listening
Tammy said uh you might want to look
into Irish slaves might be a good show
topic yeah I think I would yeah I was
thinking because I read a couple books
about that yeah people forget that the
Irish are slaves here yeah
yeah the poor Irish they always yeah I
picked on and then uh the railroad
slaughtered [__] hundreds of them at
a time you evidently with a machine gun
Irish Chinese yeah Irish and Chinese
when they were building those railroads
and they were buried along the sides of
the railroad tracks
and nobody knows nobody knows exactly
what happened
but you know the railroads were powerful
back then they had their own armies
their own courts that can send its
people to death
that's how [__] badass the railroads
back then people worried about big Tech
today and [__] man the railroads in the
1800s I mean they should have had people
killed and nobody did anything yeah
everybody's like well I suppose that's
how they were worse than the British
East India Company
you know which they would do some weird
[__] to the Chinese but man that'd be a
whole other show to be honest yeah also
that's also a fascinating time yeah they
were kind of like a Mercantile mercenary
so yeah of course I'm not saying it's
great nowadays I'm just saying that
that's a lot better I think it was worse
a lot worse back in the day there was
like no repercussions no because there
was no
I mean there was really no legal
ramifications they had money they were a
corporation they could just basically do
what they wanted it was like yeah okay I
suppose up well the difference today
we're basically being and look me and
Jenny were some pre-internet
[__] the internet has changed
the [__] game
or shows like this when it never existed
back in the day
uh it's loosening the Stranglehold over
information and the power of elite
ruling families really that control
governments and and corporations
um they're like something out of the
Roman era uh the ruling families they're
at least a lot of them maybe not all of
them but a lot of them are bad and uh
governments not just the US government
but governments work for them not you
and it's always been that way
when we talk about the railroad
companies
machine gun in Chinese and [__] Irish
they're doing that not for the
government they're doing that for the
rich people that own the government all
right people forget how they are how how
the hierarchy actually works the
government are servants to the oligarchs
not the other way around
and uh
now they have the internet the stories
can get out and be disseminated
problems aren't governments per se the
problem is the governments are [__]
under the control of bad people that are
oligarchs
well that's why I kind of always say
that as much as people piss and moan
about the internet
um I I don't think I would want to go
back no
at all like sure it brings up a whole
host of new problems but it solves a lot
of problems as well the big problems the
main problem for the past 200 years
maybe you go back to 400 years really
back in back in The Honky motherland
with the church the problem was is that
without an internet the ruling class can
control the information that you get
and with that control they can shape
your opinions
and one of the things that they tend to
do is shape your opinion away from the
evil [__] that they do they don't want
you to know about that
so they're gonna raise you on Fables
and I was going out
fighting Wars and doing crazy [__] back
in the 90s against [__] the Iraq and
I'm still friends with all these guys
what they told us back that was all lies
and it didn't serve America it didn't
Serve American people
it served oligarchs and the court and
the corporations and the companies that
they owned and controlled
it's just is a scam
I don't trust any um none of them not
anymore
the people have to know
what the actual chain of command is you
know you can elect anybody you want to
and they're still going to work for the
people that have the money
it's been that way since Rome
they were I got really really important
but now we can at least talk about it at
least here in this country
but they'll try to stop that too
but you can't stop the internet
that [__] cat's out of the bag yeah I
was gonna say I don't think you can't
stop that there's no putting that Genie
back in the bottle that's for sure the
only thing which like I said it
shouldn't be there's only one thing they
could do is try to kill [__] power
all right in other words there's no
electric power then you'd be able to
stop the internet
but as soon as electric power is stopped
the United States and the entire West is
now weak and open to Invasion the
Russians or the Chinese would just come
in here and Liberate the place
I think they're smart enough to know not
to do that because their own [__] like
depends on that yeah yeah so it's like
they're not going to shoot themselves
they won't do it like that a lot of
these people that are trying to collapse
[__] and control [__] and trying to
adapt the Chinese model here in the
United States because they think they're
controlling it and the people that are
fomenting rebellions and counter
rebellions and what's called
destabilization it's a process
the people that are destabilizing the
United States think that they can ride a
tiger
they can't ride a tiger chaos is chaos
they their [__] will be on the menu too
okay these [__] are smart
they're very intelligent
but they've never been in a [__] fist
fight
how do you think they're gonna fare in a
[__] Global Revolution or a global
World War
as soon as their money becomes
meaningless
their hired security goes wait a minute
this dude that I'm working for he did
this [__]
and he's not rich anymore kill him let's
take his [__] oh by the way get that
helicopter where's the [__] sex
slaves where is the where's the Harem
let's go visit the Harem because they
got all that [__] on these look at sex
islands and [__] soon as this [__]
situation as soon as this situation
crumbles the security turns on them and
that's what happened in Roman Empire all
the time you know I mean Emperors got
killed because [__] praetorian guard
turned on him
so yeah
they will shoot themselves in the foot
they are that stupid but
or at least some of them will we'll see
we'll see
Camp guys that I heard about a dude that
had a cherry seed inside his nose since
he was a kid he had forgotten about it
and it showed up on a dental x-ray I
heard about that I remember hearing
about that yeah a long time ago I mean I
guess that could you stick [__] up your
nose when you're a kid and you just like
forget all about it it could just be in
there Ben says there was a really nice
all you can eat Sri Lankan Buffet where
I used to live that sounds good food was
great but a few times I saw people
unwell out the front I guess you mean
puking they also got closed a couple
times by the health department
Hugo says uh Guillermo del Toro is
making Frankenstein I just sent my
resume wish me luck well good luck I
don't know what you sent your resume for
but you know Ben says Red Lobster yeah
so
Red Lobster
um I'm actually a pretty big fan of Red
Lobster one I'm pretty good yeah the uh
the cheddar bay biscuits are really good
all you can eat oh you can eat yeah they
just keep bringing them uh yeah fill up
on bread
well I think part of the problem I try
to only eat one Cheddar Bay Biscuit
because it's like I want the stuff but I
have a problem and I don't know if it's
just Red Lobster in particular or if
it's just because a lot of the food is
fried because it's happened to me
um when I tried to get stuff that wasn't
all fried too is that every time I eat
at Red Lobster
um
maybe it's just the portion size maybe
the portion sizes are too big but it's
like every time I eat there it's like I
get to a point where it's like yeah I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna throw up and
sometimes I do like sometimes I like
kind of like not throw up throughout but
like you know kind of gag and [__] like
that and like throw up a little bit like
in the parking lot so it's like I'm not
really sure if
I don't know I think it's just the
quantity because it's and I've known
like some Europeans that came here on
vacation
and they will eat in an American
restaurant and be like they can't
believe the amount of food that they'll
give you and it's like I get that
because
look it's like I can't eat a large
amount of food like whenever we get a
koiwan
which like I said is an all-you-can-eat
Chinese buffet I can eat maybe two
plates and then after that I'm I'm gonna
have a hard time
um you know what I mean and I'm just
like I really need to stop eating right
now or I'm gonna like puke all over my
lap
um but
I just I I can't imagine like because
Tom will go in there and he'll eat he's
a huge a whole plate of uh boiled shrimp
and then he'll go in and like he just
keeps going back and getting plates and
plates and then he'll get like two or
three things of like ice cream at the
end and I'm just like where the [__] are
you putting all this I get it yeah it's
like I could eat two plates and then I'm
like yeah I'm gonna heft I I better like
stop eating right now and I usually like
the last few times I haven't even like
been able to like put any ice cream in
it and I don't eat a lot no as long as
it's meat I can keep eating it no I
can't no yeah I can't I just if it's
something like rice or pasta I can't eat
a lot of it but that's the thing we guys
might want we don't eat any no rice no
noodles nope no nothing because they
have all that obviously they have fried
rice they have like all the they have lo
mein they have all that stuff we don't
need any of that
um meat yeah we just eat meat and
vegetables that's it yeah
um you know all I eat in there I'll eat
fish I'll eat shrimp I eat scallops
um crab maybe if they have it
um peppers steak mushrooms
that's it like uh that's it I don't I
don't get any carbs I don't get any like
anything like that well you might get a
little bit of carbs because we eat the
wontons I ate one I ate one pork
dumpling last year because those are
good yeah so I will get those but it's
like I don't eat
I don't yeah I pretty much don't eat
anything and like the last couple times
we went I couldn't even I was like I
don't even I didn't get any dessert I
didn't get any ice cream or anything
okay so it's like sometimes I'll get
fruit like if they have watermelon I'll
have that but it's like other than that
but yeah we just eat like
steak and fish and shrimp and yeah I ate
a lot of fish fishing's good whatever
fish and stuff they have I usually get
that but even then good for your diet
yeah yeah like I said no rice no noodles
as much as I love noodles I do but I
don't get any
because it fills you up
and it's too many calories
too many calories
yeah I got really behind Victor said the
first churches opened across the street
from the Alamo
I guess they're still around I mean I
haven't seen one around here I haven't
seen one in a while but like I said we
don't where we live is kind of rural
so there's not it's not like we're
driving and seeing like fast food places
I drive
you know miles and miles down the street
and all I see is like people's farms and
Fields and [__] I don't I don't really
see if there's churches near me
Gadget 3 said what is grits
[__] man don't [__] bring me on that
[__] he's Scottish yeah
church is Texas Chicken we have those is
it that
wait is it called Texas chickens I
thought it was just churches okay that's
what it says here grits is hominy yeah
and they soak it in I know this is gonna
sound gross they soak it in lie until it
kind of like
blows up a little bit like popcorn she
already kind of messed up
Harmony
grits is made out of hominy hominy is
corn yeah
dried cracked corn like the kind you get
to give to cattle
you put that into a big old [__]
Barrel fill it full of water and put lye
in it that's what I said yeah but you
didn't tell them it was corn
grits are corn
yeah uh when you put lye on [__] corn
corn kernels cracked corn kernels it'll
pop like popcorn
that's what it is like but it'll be like
a soft popcorn the consistency almost
kind of like
beans maybe like cooked beans
where you can take that piece of hominy
that's a popped cop popped kernel
and and mash it up and blend it
and then dehydrate it
and it becomes these little dry grits I
mean it's sand it looks kind of like
Cream of Wheat yeah if you know what
cream of wheat is
um it's like that but corn yeah you know
what I mean but it's like the same
because it doesn't taste like that no
but it's like the same kind of
consistent so if these little
gritty things it's almost kind of like
cornmeal
well you take that
and put that in boiling hot water and
it'll reconstitute and it'll become
something like a porridge like it'll be
no polenta it's a lot like yeah it's
kind of like it's more like polenta when
it's done and people who don't know
what grits are if you told them like you
gave if you spiced them up
and told and gave them to a European and
told him it was polenta they probably
would think it was polenta
but it's it is kind of similar
it's Harmony corn
it's good real good
well you can't just eat it plain because
it doesn't really taste like anything
it's it's just like anything else it's
just kind of like one of those things
that's just like a like a baseline thing
that you can like dress up one of the
big things in the south is shrimp and
grits yeah
um which obviously is what it sounds
like you have like grits you have shrimp
in there and there's like all kind of
different spices and stuff like that and
it's if it's done well it's fantastic I
like Cajun cheese shrimp and grits
that's where you got the grits
with Velveeta cheese
which makes it [__] cheesy Velveeta
is not cheese though it's not cheese but
it's Velveeta yes
[Laughter]
you could probably put cheddar in there
but you'd be wasting your time it's
probably better to just put the [__]
Velveeta in there to give it that smooth
attack
and then you put that in it and then you
might want to put a little bit of bacon
bits for flavor because southern food is
always better with any kind of bacon in
it put a little bit of that in it wait
everything's better then you [__]
shake some like maybe Tony sasheries
[__] Cajun seasoning in it or the
Creole seasoning that'll work too
I shall make it slightly reddish and
then you put
boiled shrimp in it that's already been
peeled put that on top of it serve it
butter
[__] crazy hell yeah you gave me a lot
is it good for you no oh absolutely not
actually it's all carbs
don't eat it every day no I mean unless
you want to die
yeah and die fat but um well whenever
like every now and then Tom will make
some not usually for breakfast but we
usually have it for like dinner lunch or
dinner yeah
um but he'll usually make them and he
usually puts bacon in the like he'll
make some bacon and then cut it up and
put bacon in there and then he'll put
like whole boiled eggs in there yeah
boiled eggs like and then you cut up the
boiled eggs and that's really and cheese
yeah you don't put the orboiled eggs in
it though what you do is you put it in
the bowl and then you put hard-boiled
right on the serving yeah so you can if
I can get a little bit of hard-boiled
egg on your spoon and then just yeah
it's like yeah it's good like that it's
good like that it'll have little bits of
bacon in it and [__] cheese and
seasoning
but you can do like I said it's they're
kind of plain on their own but you can
do all kind of things the same basically
the same kind of things that you could
do with polenta you can do the same kind
of things my dad and his friends that
generation they wouldn't put anything in
them except salt pepper and butter if
you see them like that as a kid and it
was good like that yeah if you seasoned
them they looked at you like oh that's
Yankee [__] they they [__] didn't
like that at all they're like the
southerners like just like just food
that's disgusting it's like that's like
a point no flavor it's like we we just
want to eat stuff with no flavor and if
you want to like Flavor something they
get all offended oh yeah like you're
being a [__]
and you don't want a flavor [__] real
cornbread I'm just like that's okay I'm
just gonna be enjoying my food over here
while you're just like breaking down
your whatever when you get cornbread
here in the states or probably overseas
[__] a real Southern or like my dad
and his buddies and [__] would [__]
turn their nose up at that and go
that's Yankee corn cake and the
cornbread tends to be in a restaurant
cake like
sweet I mean that's good too dang it is
good but that's not cornbread real
cornbread is [__] only about an inch
high it's very coarse and dry and it's
there's no flavor in it there's no sugar
in it or any there might be a little bit
of salt in it but it's just something
you use almost like a big cornbread
cracker they'll use it to sop up
drippings and [__]
you know what I mean they'll have like
[__] what they call that [__]
greens collard greens and [__] pot
liquor and [__] you use it like that
it's it it's
um coarse uh kind of dry bread very dry
bread actually crumbly
um
the outside of it's very crispy because
it's been cooked in a baked in a cast
iron skillet yeah so it's real crispy on
the outside of it it's good but it
it's not like the real Southern
cornbread is not like even the cornbread
or average Southerner and eats here
around here in a suburban area
well you don't need them not anymore you
go to Boston Market for example and they
have cornbread there like you they have
little pieces of cornbread and you can
get that as a side and it's good but
it's pretty sweet yeah that's not
cornbread whereas like cornbread
cornbread like I said it's very very
dense and it's very thin it's only about
that about an inch tie yeah it needs a
[__] ton of butter though and it's dry
and when you chew it it pops and
crackles
it's real gritty
and Camp guy said my old man would eat
cornbread soaked in buttermilk yeah you
had to like soak it in so yeah just
eating it plain you could eat it plain
but
why would you like you know old school
Southerners love that though
they liked it or they pretended to I
think they did like it my dad didn't
like it he didn't call that other stuff
cornbread I mean he'd eat he'd eat it
the other stuff he says that's not
cornbread
they wanted that real dry
crunchy
thing about snapping pops like they're
sand
I kind of feel like too you would always
like eat it with other things that you
would like dip it yeah they were dipping
a phrase so it wasn't like you were just
eating it like by itself or nothing it
was meant to absorb pot liquor yeah and
[__] drippings
which people are like what the [__] is
that this
well it's a long story it's this it's
kind of the same function as like a
Yorkshire pudding yeah would be where
they you know they which Yorkshire
puddings are really good or they're more
like did I want to say they're more like
popovers but they're not sweet they're
Savory but you dip them in the beef
rabies you know what I mean because you
have it with like your big roast beef
and everything like that so you would
dip it in that so it's kind of a similar
thing like cornbread is something that
you would generally dip in meat gravy or
well most of the time I saw them
dripping dipping them into [__]
greens yeah that too collard greens yeah
which had drippings in there which was
like it had cooked
collard greens which is kind of like the
tops of turnips I believe
and there was like a
and that was cooked in bacon so there
was kind of like a bacony oily broth
with that and they're soaking that broth
up
cornbread and eat greens
there might be a little bit of onions in
the greens yeah just call them greens
well turnip greens greens they're all in
the same family yeah yeah
yeah and they all taste kind of similar
yeah the stuff that you could grow out
in your backyard
because
Mississippi and Alabama parts of
Louisiana and
[__] Tennessee it was subsistence
farming that's where Elvis came from he
was also
every house had about an acre of land
behind it
they had a farm where they were growing
food
Southerners were poor
but they were never hungry
they had lots of food and it was good
living no pollution or anything fresh
water wells
uh it was just good country it was like
you know good country living
and they had a lot of food and they
would trade
it grew butter beans if I can when I was
a little kid I remember old ladies just
sitting around picking butter beans yeah
I remember that remember all that
picking butter beans things and they're
sitting there in there I remember
smoking beans when I was a kid yeah and
butter beans were [__] delicious for
a bowl yeah I remember doing that butter
beans or little green beans you could
cook them and [__] they were soft as
butter I think that's what they were
talking about it's weird I wasn't a
really big bean fan when I was growing
up I liked them later on because Tammy
was saying black eyed peas or pinto
beans uh Black Eyed Peas I'm gonna go
pinto beans um although I'm gonna say
like Black Eyed Peas I always hated
Black Eyed Peas because my grandmother
made them all the time and I was just
kind of like she'd always put like the
ham hock in there and all that and I was
just trying to remember rice yeah I
didn't really like them but
I I don't like a lot of things that kind
of developed a taste for them later on
you made a black eyed pea Curry yeah one
time that was amazing it was like out of
this [__] world I'm gonna tell you
guys something
when the US Army went to Iraq
on the second mission that they went
there
they took black eyed peas with them
and Iraqis loved black eyed peas and
evidently Black Eyed Peas became
an Iraqi favorite you could evidently go
to a rock and still find Black Eyed Peas
now and the reason why the Army had
Black Eyed Peas is in the in the the US
Army in general
is Southerners that's his recruiting
uh
militaries which is the language the US
Army speaks it's a bunch of acronyms and
[__] everything is delivered in a
Southern accent
the old
[__] menus when you went to [__] a
chow hall to get fed is all southern
food all right uh
the US Army was Southern
which seems to be upsetting people
because
a lot of the [__] army forts were
named after Confederate generals
it's because it's all in the South and
the recruits all came from a South
and the Confederate generals and the
Union Generals all went to the same
military academies
it didn't really matter it's just
it was Americans fighting Americans
so I don't think there's any reason to
[__]
you know Lee and all those guys they
were good dudes they were just as good
as the guys in the north they weren't
fighting to defend slavery they were
they were fighting to defend the South
you had black people in the in the
[__] Confederate Army after Sherman
[__] burned down Atlanta
there's a lot of [__] that they don't
teach you about about the war between
Americans you know but uh what are you
doing what's this nothing okay
but it's just it's funny that
foreign
Rockies like them it's funny
I wonder if you can still get them there
I don't know yeah if anybody's in your
rock tell me if I can uh if you can get
Black Eyed Peas there evidently the the
Iraqis loved them they're a good P it's
a bean really but yeah it's not a p it's
not a p yeah it's a b it's a little for
you foreigners it's a little beige Bean
with a black circle on it and it looks
like it's got a little black eye on it
and they they're [__] really good for
some reason
um and this is probably a southern thing
but I feel like Black Eyed Peas
because my grandmother would make them
every New Year's
it was a New Year's thing yeah that's
what you're supposed you're supposed to
make ham
and black eyed peas yeah and greens yeah
that was your New Year's thing man my
grandma she made that everything my
grandmother and my dad [__] made that
all the time
I mean she made it other times too but
that well like New Year's you had to
make it Black Eyed Peas were a couple
times a week
in that house yeah like I said she made
it all the time but that was kind of
like that New Year's that was like you
had to have ham and Black Eyed Peas I
Got a [__] ton of try Black Eyed Peas I
Got and you're making me want to bust
them out
well like I said the best thing you ever
made with black eyed peas was that curry
curry that Curry that you made I don't
remember exactly what I did because
remember we had that we remember we had
that big party yeah and we had a lot of
vegetarians and vegans that were coming
and we were doing a whole Indian food
spread so some people are bringing stuff
um and we knew that some people there
like black vegan black metal Chef was
coming so we knew that some people that
were like vegan vegan but we knew some
people vegetarians so we wanted to make
Indian food is really good because you
can make a lot of it at one time one uh
that's one and two it's easy to make
vegetarian because a lot of the dishes
are vegetarian or work with meat or
without it and it keeps for a long time
and matter of fact a lot of Indian food
gets better like you make it and then
it's good that day but then like the
second or third day it's like phenomenal
fourth sometimes right and it's like so
it's really good as like leftovers so
you can make it ahead and then like by
the time you know the party comes like
it'll be like at Peak deliciousness what
are people talking about there and it's
just somebody they're wishing me happy
birthday yeah I was gonna say Oracle uh
says hippo birdie to you Tom thank you
thank you very much Kevin Smith also
says happy birthday to you yeah it's his
birthday tomorrow it's his birthday
tomorrow everybody yeah but yeah but
um so you made
butter chicken yeah for the carnivores
yeah because that was I think Dimitri
asked you was like please make the
butter because you make like the world's
best butter chicken it's like seriously
well I use the Shan mixed for that one
[__] right but well you experiment
with different yeah mixes too I mean
that Shan mix is the best one my
favorite is a Pakistani [__] butter
chicken mix called [__] made by Shan
yeah in the yellow box yeah it's yellow
right there yeah I like I like the
Indian and Indian mix too made by
[__] National that's pretty good but
I just like Shan Shan's the best one
yeah the national one's okay too that's
like the pale blue box I think
but yeah if you go to like the the Asian
market yeah they have like a million
different like pre-mixed spice mixes for
whatever dish you want to make
um but and we've tried like all the
different brands but to be honest like
for butter chicken Shannon's about like
Shannon yeah because it's like it we've
had some that were like that I thought
were too spicy because butter chicken is
not supposed it's supposed to have like
a little bit of kick but not much it's
supposed to be like fairly mild and
we've had some and I don't remember if
it was National if it was some other
brand but I remember us making one uh
batch of butter chicken with like a
different brand and it was like real
spicy butter chicken is kind of like
General Tso's chicken rather [__]
with Chinese food no two dishes are the
same they're not okay well it came out
of a restaurant right originally both of
those recipes came out of a restaurant I
think General Tso's chicken came out of
a casino in Taiwan yeah and
Nobody Knows the original recipe of
either one of those no uh I think the
original butter chicken recipe came out
of the Taj I think it was from the top I
think well that's what Gordon said like
because if Gordon did that like
miniseries where he was like going to
All Around India and like right and he
went to the he went to India and [__]
went to the Taj and had the butter
chickens and then he tasted he was like
oh
okay
because it's not spicy no
so it's
when it comes to [__] butter chicken
and [__]
um General Tso's chicken which is a
every version you've had is a copy
they're trying to copy something that
came
from a chef in a [__] high-end
restaurant he didn't release the recipe
so that means [__] it's gonna be a
lot of room for for [__] Evolution
yeah they don't taste alike you know
yeah we've tried like lots of different
butter chicken mixes
they're all different like markedly
different yeah they're different flavors
like it's all kind of it's all
demonstrably the same dish kind of same
right but there's there's variations
that are like that are um significant
enough that you and I don't want to hurt
any Indian feelings here but when it
comes to those [__] mixes the
Pakistani version the Shan which is
Pakistan that's my favorite I like that
one the better than the Indian mixes I
did too although
I've uh you can also you don't need the
mixes you can just do it on your own
yeah it's just easier and I've Just Seen
well you can't get that Shan flavor
though yeah through the mix so I've
tried a lot of Home recipes that came
from India of how they do butter chicken
and they're all pretty good they're all
different they're all good I mean
they're all like they're [__] sham
they're all delicious it's kind of like
the Big Mac when you want a Big Mac you
want a Big Mac
version you want that you want that yeah
yeah because like I said he makes butter
chicken all the time but like sometimes
we use the Shand mix and sometimes we
don't have it so we use another mixer he
just mixes his own because I bought him
um one of those what do they call it I
know there's a word for it but it's like
this big round thing that it's like you
put all the Indian spices in like they
have they each have their own little cup
and they all have their own and you can
keep track of all your like spices and
stuff so I bought them one of those
because we make a lot of Indian food
so sometimes he uses his own mixture
um but I like I said I gotta say that
Shane one is just I don't know there's
something about that one that I really
like and I'm not really sure what it is
but
um
he made some butter chicken the other
day I don't think so I don't think we
had a Shand mix though but I don't know
what makes these were but that was
pretty good also but like I said some of
them are like spicier than others and I
kind of feel like butter chicken is not
it's it seems like it's supposed to have
like a little bit of a kick but it's not
supposed to be really spicy I think
people have a misperception with people
that don't
um eat any Indian food like they think
that all Indian food just like they
think all Thai food is like supposed to
be super spicy and it's not
um a lot of Indian food is like actually
pretty mild and honestly if you go to an
Indian restaurant they'll make it
however you want them to make it because
I don't like super spicy food either I
can't eat it it like upsets my stomach
so
you know so whenever I go to like
memories of India or whatever I always
get milder medium I can't like Tom likes
super super spicy but I can't eat it
like that it just
uh my my digestive system is not it does
not um want to deal with it that's all
I'm gonna say about that but yeah so I
so I can't really eat so I can't relate
it so I can't super spicy stuff
um but yeah
Tammy said it's like spaghetti sauces
yeah family has their own recipe yeah
and you could make spaghetti sauce a
hundred times and I mean Tom makes pasta
sauce spaghetti sauce like all the time
every time it's like slightly slowly
it's a little bit different yeah it's
slightly slightly different I'm not
measuring
yeah do it by eye well I think that's
probably why I'm gonna take I'm
finishing and I'm going yeah that's good
just got to make sure that the damn salt
to salt to uh sugar ratio is correct
yeah that's the main thing and you
mainly just do it by taste yeah and it's
like you know that might change from day
to day yeah you know some days I tend to
like like tomato sauce is a little bit
sweeter because if it's like a little
bit too bitter like I said it gives me
heartburn but you know what I mean
uh Tammy said uh the hubs family does
that for the new year I'm from
Pennsylvania we always had pork and
sauerkraut for New Year's yeah that
sounds German I've heard I've heard of
that yeah that's very German very German
yeah but like I said for whatever reason
every time it was New Year's
my grandmother would insist she's like
We're yeah she would make a ham like a
hunting ham and black eyed peas and
greens we have that in the South though
too and Cornbread we have that in the
South though too because with pork chops
and sauerkraut with mustard and potatoes
we need that
just it wasn't real common I never had
sauerkraut growing up you didn't have it
oh we had it
um now my grandmother would make but she
made pork chops all the time probably at
least once a week maybe twice
but she would usually have pork chops
with potatoes and mac and cheese is what
they would usually have and green beans
that's what they that's what that would
usually go together with
still got a pretty good crowd out there
if you guys can go ahead and hit the
like button for us that'll help us out
and then Oracle said chili is always
different yeah a little bit so it's like
everybody has their kind of their own
thing
I've made a lot of different kinds of
chili but I've kind of [__] settled
on the fact that chili is not supposed
to have any beans in it
you know that Jen remember every time
well isn't there a big debate in Texas
because is it Texas Chili is like not
supposed to have beans because they're
like well that's not real chili if it
has beans yeah because I know there's a
big controversy I've come to the
conclusion that yeah it's not supposed
to happen I mean you can put it to me
well [__] man it's better without my
grandmother made chili and she puts
spaghetti in there so you know yeah
that's [__] funny I've seen people
pour chili over spaghetti noodles yeah
yeah
yeah every pretty much every time she
made chili she put spaghetti in there
I wasn't a fan I wasn't a fan of that
Oracle said speaking is a text and yes
we have opinions about chili yes so I've
heard I'm not from Texas but I I do kind
of try to keep up on food stuff and yeah
Texans uh are very
uh polarized about their chili opinions
beans or no beans but yeah like you said
it's well we've talked about this before
I kind of feel like every country's
Cuisine has an equivalent
of chili yeah well chili is curry I mean
essentially yeah it's pretty much the
same pretty much the same same math same
idea and it has a lot of similar spices
in it yeah that chill that Curry has
I've always heard that chili was Indian
yeah maybe and I always thought they
were talking about American Indian they
may be talking about India Indians
oh maybe
well it does have a lot of the same [__]
in it a lot of the same [__] right it's
the same method it's got chili powder
it's got cumin it's got all that kind of
stuff so cinnamon sometimes what
somebody told me they found a channel
where you were you seeing this I found
this channel uh from searching for Jello
content oh really okay where what
channel are you talking about this
channel oh watching a decent giallo my
my dear killer and listen to y'all good
times oh okay
oh that's cool yeah yeah well thank you
man I love yellow movies yeah like I
just
I don't know why it's just it's my thing
speaking of movies and I'm not gonna
like spoil too much about it because
we're going to talk about this on Sunday
but last night I finally finally got to
see the new Brandon Cronenberg movie
infinity pool it was good it's pretty
good I loved it
yeah I know like opinions like it seemed
like most of the I kind of did a sort of
like cursory glance over the uh reviews
today and it does seem like mostly it
got positive reviews I think this is his
best movie so brother I know he's only
made three movies okay and if you don't
know he's the first one was called
antiviral and that came out in 2012
which is also good and if you haven't
seen that like I recommend that second
one which was kind of like his big
one that everybody heard about was
possessor which is also great
um this one I don't know I was really
into this one and and I was thinking
about it all day today he does come up
with some weird ideas he's very much
like his dad it's messed up but he's
like his dad but he's not copying but
he's also got his own thing yeah he's
got his own thing like they're exploring
similar themes but like in a slightly
different way yeah and I don't know I'm
into it I was really into this movie
it's on um if you have Hulu it's on Hulu
they just put it on Hulu
so and is I think possessor is on there
too so I don't know about antiviral I
don't know where that is I watched it
like a year ago or so but yeah like uh
Brandon craterberg he's killing it
killing it but yeah we'll talk about it
Sunday but I really really liked
infinity pool I have seen some people
being like what
the reason I wanted to watch it well I
wanted to watch it because it's Brandon
Cronenberg and I'd seen his other movies
and I was just like so I'm in a theater
yeah we saw well no we saw Crimes of the
future that was David kernenberg oh it's
a different one that was yeah that was
he's got two he's got two sons no okay
that was that was the dad oh okay that's
right Crimes of the future was David
Cronenberg that's right that's right we
saw that in the theater I thought it was
the sun okay we saw possessor yeah
um on Hulu Okay yeah like a year ago or
something yeah and then anti-viral which
is the first movie which came out in
2012. I I don't think you saw it but I
watched right yeah and it was really I
might have seen that Cronenberg senior
movie was good yeah although yeah I this
might be controversial I liked this one
better
it's different it's it's they're I think
they're both good they're both good
they're both good yeah but I really I
really got into this I had a good idea
everything about this one I was like
into it I was into the score I was in
like the concept and I told him after I
was like man I wish I had thought of
this [__] idea yeah if you guys
haven't seen it see it
if you can it was on HBO it's it no it's
uh Hulu Hulu Okay it's Hulu yeah but um
it's definitely I did see some like uh
it's creepy opinions like and most of
the I loved this this is one of the
reasons I wanted to see it other than
it's just being Brandon Cronenberg was
that all of the horror channels that I
subscribed to you can see like on the
thumbnails they were all just like what
the [__] did I just watch and I'm like
oh I gotta see that
[Laughter]
although it is I understand yeah it
wasn't it's
well I'm jaded
um you know I've seen some weird [__]
this is the weirdest [__] I've ever seen
it's weird but it's not the weirdest
thing it's a good idea it's actually a
great concept and honestly it's not
here's the thing I kind of feel like
some people are just kind of like oh
like it's like they didn't know what was
going on to me it seemed like very
straightforward it was a very
straightforward story close attention to
it and I can understand what was going
on right that's what I mean like he was
just like talking to people on his
tablet and stuff like that and he still
like a couple times he's like wait what
is what is happening and like I explain
it he's like oh okay I got you yeah but
it's like it's not a difficult concept
to understand not at all
I'll I'll give you a little hit
some people are going on a vacation
in a fictional country they named the
country but this country doesn't exist
and it's kind of a backwards country but
it it has real good night life and a
good [__] resorts
part of their laws are
if you kill somebody even accidentally
the family of the person who got killed
had us the right to take revenge out on
you
so if the cops get you they'll hand you
over to that family
all right that family will try to kill
you you can also well no they will kill
you they will kill you yeah they'll tie
you up [__] stab you to death or
whatever
now you have an option to be executed I
think before don't you didn't they say
would you would rather be actually gave
you didn't they be an out okay okay now
the out was yeah well we're spoiling it
yeah well I don't know I kind of feel
like no no no no no no no don't say it
well some guy goes on vacation there and
[__] he's a writer and uh he hooked
he hooks him and his girlfriend he's got
his wife yeah his wife yeah he's got a
[__] badass little light-skinned wife
who's really really rich yeah real rich
and she's supporting his career yeah and
she runs into this other couple and the
other couple's got this hot ass blonde
who's just Mia gothi guys yeah from X
and Trump [__] him and trying to do it
just sit I still need to see Pearl by
the way and and the husband's in on it
you know there's there's swingers
and he's like yeah go ahead [__] you
know whatever he didn't give a [__]
well this dude accidentally kill
somebody they got drunk and [__] [__]
Heat
but they're riding around in a [__]
car big old [__] Cadillac
old-fashioned Cadillac and [__] ran
over the dude out in the middle of the
country who's just running out in front
of the car and they ran from the scene
but they somehow figured out who it was
to hit the that hit the kid hit the dude
it was a dude and they they grabbed the
rider well they knew who it was because
of the car that's because they had
rented it from somebody at the resort
that's right she remembers all the
details yeah
I'm drunk but I still remember yeah so
he's being accused of murder and they're
gonna [__] give him over to this
other family
but there's a way out and the way out is
[__] bizarre
what a great [__] idea yeah I was
just so into the concept for this and
then they start getting off on the way
out once they realize that there's a way
out of committing crimes they just
commit more and more crimes well the
thing about it is like there's there's
kind of like I don't know maybe we
should save it for Sunday because it's
just like we're gonna talk about it on
Sunday but subjective perspective says
uh infinity pool was great I still need
to see the uncut version yeah there is
an uncut version that has like some [__]
shots in it and stuff this one is pretty
um explicit
but there is I think the version that's
on Hulu is the R-rated version and there
is an nc17 version
um that has like close-ups of dicks you
know
blowing their loads and why not yeah you
must be talking about what to do is
taking a leak and she comes up behind
him starts jerking him off well I think
there was that because there was that
big sequence too where he was like
hallucinating like on that drug and
there was all that weird like orgy [__]
going on yeah so I think there was more
in that um area too but I think they cut
some of this stuff American couple and a
[__] European couple in this
weird-ass fictional Country Resort
one of the European couples bunch of
swingers and [__] they accidentally
killed a dudes weird [__] happens and it
gets weirder
it's kind of like in a way like we're
gonna talk about it on Sunday but it's
like it's better if you go into it
because I didn't really know they're not
knowing how weird I saw the trailer like
a long time ago
um so I was like man that looks [__]
up I'm into that
um but I didn't know exactly what the
plot was I didn't look anything up
beforehand I was like no I just want to
watch that so like last night I got home
from work I'm like I'm watching this
[__] tonight I got my snacks I got my
drink I said I got all snuggled up into
bed and all comfortable and I said I'm
gonna watch this [__] movie and it's
like I got really into it I was really
into it I thought it was good I want to
see it again
uh I want to see I want to see the other
Cronenberg movie again though too which
Crimes of the future yeah crimes that is
also on Hillary I want to I want to see
it also that's also unhill because I
only saw it once and you know how does
the Cronenberg movie you got to see him
a couple times before you [__] pick
everything up well yeah because that's
kind of like the whole because I
remember I was watching his [__] going
back to the brood when I was a little
kid man I loved it brood and videos he's
probably like my fit well I don't know I
was I was gonna say my second favorite
but [__] well I mean David Lynch is my
first favorite like that's always gonna
happen but it scared me but but the
thing about it is like David Cronenberg
and John Carpenter I can't decide
Carpenter but they're but they're
different it's like really hard to
compare them yeah and I'm not sure
carpenter made all the movies that had
his name on him I'm not sure well the
thing about Carpenter too was that he
made like some absolute masterpieces
like yes whereas Cronenberg all of his
movies yeah they're all the same have
been good quality have been worth
watching yeah have been worth watching
all the corona breaks movies are good
right are good quality and his son's
movies from what I've seen are just as
good like I said this was infinity pool
was his third one
um you should you would probably like
antiviral that was his first one okay um
and that was I really liked that a lot
that came out in 2012. I don't remember
where I watched it I thought it was
probably on Hulu too but that was like a
year or two ago that I watched that and
we watched possessor
I think we reviewed it on here somewhere
and I really liked that too
but yeah he's like he's exploring the
same themes as his dad but he's not
really like copying his dad yeah not
really no he's just kind of continuing a
tradition but yeah but he's doing doing
his own wheelhouse but he's got like his
own thing going on right it's not like
the kind of situation where you have
[__] a singer and then the singer
dies and then the child of the singer
starts a music career it's not like that
right right it's not like that
um yeah it's not it's it's maybe it's
maybe it's an nepotism but I mean that's
unavoidable but at least he's got his
own Vision like I said it's in the same
wheelhouse but he's taking that same
spirit that his dad was doing and going
like okay yeah I can do that but I'm
gonna do a little bit of my own way but
you'll see if you like that if you like
my dad's work you'll like my work too
you will somebody said I saw this in a
review and I thought this is Cronenberg
it is Chrono it is Cronenberg somebody
said this in a review and I thought this
was like a really good succinct uh you
know kind of distillation of what the
difference between them was they're like
whereas David Cronenberg his Fascination
is with
bodily disintegration or with um the way
that your insides are like uh mirrored
on your outsides like by your body
mutating or whatever whereas like
Brandon Cronenberg is more worried about
his his kind of thematic thing is more
like the corruption of your soul
you know what I mean yeah he's like well
he does body horror too and like this
movie um infinity pool has some like
pretty gruesome but he's gonna do it's
very violent I got you yeah it is but
yeah but it's more it's more about the
disintegration of your soul or your
morality is more about yeah and his
other movies were like that too he saw
Crimes of the future we saw that in the
in this in the theater yeah which is
David Cronenberg yeah David Cronenberg
and there was only one other person in
the theater watching it and it was a guy
about my age and he was sitting in front
of his member and he was yeah the big
guy you know yeah six two six three kind
of [__] heavyset guy and after that
[__] movie
he stood up and he looked at us it's
like what the [__] was that
which is hilarious
compared to other Cronenberg movies I
thought it was like pretty it was it was
weird but it wasn't but he knew who
Cronenberg was this is a [__]
chronography because he goes yeah I
guess
because what the [__] is he talking
about
but no it was good the crimes the future
was good I really I did I really liked
it into the future Cronenberg senior was
never [__] um he was never [__]
tied down to things like reality or
plausibility it was just I feel like
something too
David Cronenberg maybe this is another
difference they don't Berg I always felt
like um some of his stuff was
slightly
satirical in the sense that he had like
a black humor like um you could tell
that David kronenberg was getting a lot
of pleasure out of
um the [__] that he was putting you know
what I mean like there was always like a
black comedy element to it which was I
mean sometimes it was subtle but it was
like always there whereas Brandon
Cronenberg I don't
I don't want to say there's no black
humor because there is but it's not as
overt or it's it's not as um detectable
yeah as David objective has been saying
a lot of stuff go ahead and see
um yeah yeah he says I left the theater
after infinity pool and didn't know how
to feel about it until the next day
after I processed I love it yeah on
honestly I watched it last night and I
was like man I'm [__] into this movie
I was into everything about it I was
into the visuals of this I love the
[__] score
um I can't when I looked up the guy that
did it but I can't remember his name
right now because I'm too drunk but um
everything about it I was just like man
I'm super into this and then like I was
thinking about it like all day today I'm
like man what a [__] that was a great
[__] movie it was a great [__]
movie and then like I was I was reading
like some other people's uh takes on it
and [__] like that and I'm just like man
I just love this movie even more
nowadays and now I want to see it like
again you know what I mean uh John
Robertson said I finally saw the haunted
palace with Vincent Price which I think
I reviewed not too long ago I love being
surprised uh I love it Vincent Price
playing a warlock just does something
for me he was I mean as great as he was
playing good guys
um I think there was something special
about Vincent Price playing a villain
because she knew he was like such a nice
dude in real life I gotta see Dr fives
too yeah we got to see that that's
another we need to review okay
um let's see who is y'all's favorite
Italian director
I mean I think it's like pretty obvious
to say Dario Argento but I'm gonna say
like I love Dario gento
um other than his more recent stuff I'm
into Dario Argento up until about
the stendhall syndrome I liked the
stentile syndrome which was what 96
after that not so much I did a review of
Sleepless or not Sleepless
um dark glasses which was like the
newest one and you know Dario's in his
80s now so the fact that he's still
making movies and dark glasses was okay
it was okay
um it wasn't anything to write home
about it was better than some of the it
was better than the card player that's
for sure and it was better than that
Abomination known as Dracula 3D so you
know what I mean but I'm gonna say
Sergio Martino I'm gonna say that's who
I'm gonna say and I'm gonna say or Lucio
fulgy and I'm gonna say Sergio Leone
I [__] love the man with no name
[__] trilogy
with Clint Eastwood Fistful of Dollars
and all that one of the Best Westerns of
all times that changed the [__]
Western game
uh and and made that made
um
Clint Eastwood
those three movies
well you could say if I can hang them
high I also made him but you know what I
mean flicking uh no I'd say Sergio Leone
and one of the best things about Sergio
was the scores that he selected he every
[__] every [__] movie he made the
score made this made the movie sound
important
the only one I haven't seen so seen yet
if anybody wants to review it send it to
me I want to see Fistful of dynamite
I remember seeing the trailer when I was
a kid but I never saw it
uh but no I [__] Sergio Leone I'd say
but like I said it's not horror that's
Western
but still yeah he was great he was great
he broke brought a post-apocalyptic
flavor to to the Old West
more accurate to the way the West Was in
a certain way well I was going to say
the weird thing about him being an
Italian director was that he almost got
the American West more than filmmakers
in America yeah well one of the things
that he got so great it was was how
Mexican the old west was because you
know
it was kind of a [__] the borders
were kind of blurred because you know
after the Mexican-American War the
United States annexed a lot of what used
to be Mexico but the Mexicans didn't
leave they stayed there and they kept
coming across
and uh there wasn't a big difference
between the old west and Mexico and
Mexicans and Americans they were all
Cowboys and vegetos and [__]
you know
volcanoes
and that's and Sergio [__] captured
that
and there were Indians going along that
at the same time and it was like after
an apocalypse
after the Mexican apocalypse because
they were the Mexicans The Mexican
government was now gone that was the end
of that era now the American era was
beginning but it was weak so it was like
happening in a Mad Max type era or place
and that's pretty accurate
subjective perspective says mine is
Mario Baba also a very good pick because
and I can't believe I didn't think of
that because Mario Baba not only did
some great [__] man some great
[__] Anthology films also arguably I
don't even know if this is arguably the
first
slasher movie Bay of blood
AKA twitch of the death nerve which I
actually like that title better so I
usually use that better I even have a
Beyblade little poster back there I
don't know if you can see it it's back
there it's a it's the Italian title but
um I would argue like a lot of people
say black Christmas
first slasher which like I said I'm not
going to argue with you too hard but um
I would argue that bay of blood is
probably the first slasher because uh
even though it's not exactly like a
slasher in the sense that there's like
one person going around killing a lot of
people um spoiler alert like pretty much
everyone's a killer but it has like a
lot of the tropes that um the slasher
movies would pick up on later on like
the POV shots and like the promiscuous
people getting killed off first and like
and all that kind of stuff so all the
stuff that you would recognize from like
a later slasher is in that and that came
out in
what 69 71 something like that like
several years before black Christmas so
you know what I mean
um but yeah oh and he also made
a very good one of the first
um Jello films also
which Dario Argenta was very uh inspired
by so you know
uh yeah beyblood to me is the first yeah
I'm gonna say like because some people
will go back and say like well psycho
was the first slasher and psycho wasn't
psycho's a great film it's a classic
um
I would but it's not really a slasher if
you're gonna go back that far to 1960 I
would argue that peeping Tom which also
came out in 1960 was a British film is
closer to a slasher than modern slashers
but if you're talking about modern
slashers then Bale blood was the first
one Bay of blood was the first one now
maybe like bait like black Christmas you
know is maybe more known but I kind of
feel like beyblood was the first
technically the first Slasher
um
what would be a unique way to do a
slasher if you had to reinvent The Reel
the wheel
man that's the thing I feel like
everything's been done it's just kind of
like it's they've gone they've done
every possibly they've gone into space
they've gone into like they [__]
they've gone meta like Cabin in the
Woods
um you know where everything was like a
simulation they've done that they've
gone the horror comedy route they've
gone I don't know it's like and it's
maybe just because my imagination is
limited but I can't really think of
anything else
they could cross breed that with and I'm
gonna say that it's like slashers I love
slashers I'm not saying that but it's
like it's never been my favorite
horror sub-genre you know what I mean my
favorite horror subgenre would probably
be either like Haunted House movies I
love Haunted House movies or Jello
movies which are actually more like
Mysteries than horror but you know what
I mean whatever it's
it's academic at this point but I kind
of feel like I don't know I don't know
honestly the stuff that I've enjoyed
lately as far as slasher media goes not
so much movies but I've read a couple of
books
lately that were kind of like slashers
that were kind of like that tickled my
bunny bone I really liked um Grady
hendricks's book uh the Final Girl
support group which was kind of like a
slasher but also like a like a
deconstruction of slashers but it was
also like a good story in its own right
so I liked that it was like an
examination of like the Final Girl trope
so I liked that
um and then there was also one who wrote
this [__] [__] I think it was a
British dude again
Adam Miller and I think was his name and
he wrote like it's actually a trilogy
but I've only read the first one and he
did a series called the first one was
called Larry and it was a like a classic
slasher but it was like a but it was
like funny you know what I mean like it
was a parody of a slasher but also like
a slasher on its own right and it was
about this guy who was a slasher villain
but he was like old now
you know what I mean and he had so he's
like wearing a pig mask and he'd go
around like at a [__] summer camp
like killing people but it's like it's
harder for him now because it's like
he's like 65 and he has like arthritis
and [__] like that so it's like it's
just really funny if you haven't read it
like I said I don't know if the other
two were funny but the first one was
like legitimately made my laugh made me
laugh my ass off it was like great what
all right well it's ten we've been
[__] streaming for a long time you
want to continue going or do you want to
uh I don't know we might have a warmer
it's it's like it's Friday night we're
not going anywhere right okay
yeah oh I'm [__] loaded that's all
right okay
yeah I like that people agree with me
that be a blood is the first slasher
because you know
I'm not gonna get all like upset about
it but I'm just saying I just kind of
feel like that's the first one well I'm
kind of fascinated by the whole
push pull the whole give and take
between the American
uh film industry in the Italian film
industry because I kind of feel like the
Italian film industry not so much
nowadays but back in the day they kind
of got like the
probably I mean
there was probably a reason that a lot
of people thought this but I kind of
feel like they had
the reputation for drifting like
rip-offs of popular American movies you
know what I mean it's like oh Jaws came
out in 1975 so then they had to like do
all these Italian knockoffs like the
last shark or
um what was that one that I saw in
Mystery Science Theater
the devil fish you know what I mean that
was not really a shark but it was kind
of like a shark
octopus hybrid or like a prehistoric
shark or something with tentacles it was
the whole thing so um so yeah so they
kind of tended to do rip-offs but the
thing about it was that there was a lot
of like give and take between the two
cultures you know I mean like they were
inspired by
like yeah a lot of the giallo films were
inspired by Alfred Hitchcock or I'm
gonna say but the thing is both of them
both Alfred Hitchcock and The Italian
Jello films were actually both
influenced by
um earlier like British Mysteries like
Edgar Wallace and stuff like that in
fact some of the stuff was based on
Edgar Wallace's books so I don't know I
think they're both like drawing from the
same well and they were both kind of
like
um you know influenced by each other and
the thing about it was John Carpenter
was like really into like Italian movies
which is where one of the reasons where
he got the idea for like Halloween like
doing slashers and stuff like that was
from Italian movies like from Jolly
movies that was where the whole idea for
the slasher came from I feel like was
from jail movies
thank you
uh yeah subjective says uh the Italian
style and Vibe can't be matched yeah
they have their own unique thing man
they have a panache it's just something
I didn't bring a lot of substance to it
they're dialogue I never I never ever
get tired of geology movies I've seen
good ones I've seen bad ones I've seen
all I've seen modern ones because now
there's been like kind of like I
wouldn't call it a trend but it's like a
mini Trend where like some horror
filmmakers now are like making modern
versions of them or making
um modern movies that are inspired by
Jello which I'm into so I've seen a
couple like that like I've reviewed some
of her on my other channel
um there was one called Francesca
that was actually me I think it was by
Argentinian filmmakers if I'm not
mistaken but they wanted to make I think
it came out in 2015 and they wanted to
make something that looked like a lost
gialo film from the 70s and
they succeeded pretty well in that
um there's also been some kind of like
more surreal ones that was one called uh
the strange color of your body's tears
which was fairly recent I think it came
out like in the last decade or so
um pretty inscrutable gotta say
um I liked it but
I'd be lying if I said I had any [__]
idea what was going on in that [__] uh
because it was like pretty surreal but
the imagery was like pretty cool and
everything the thing about it is like a
lot of giallo movies are
um I'm gonna say that like plot is not
the most important thing style but a lot
of them do have plots that you can kind
of follow like some of them don't
entirely make sense they're like well we
just put this in there because we
thought it looked cool which you know
fair enough but most of the time like
the plots do make sense like you could
tell somebody what the plot was and
they'd be like okay I get that Victor
Garcia's understanding that we didn't
cross the border border crossed us by
the time I was talking about uh uh
Sergio Leone capturing the
Mexican-American War era where if I can
we add next a bunch of the [__]
continent
um
yeah uh a lot of Mexicans just stayed
where they were and uh they ended up
being Americans that way so I think it's
it is funny but that's just the way
history works you know
Zach says what's the best written GLA
you've seen
um okay
I'm into as far as like screenplays go
like I said I like a lot of Dario
argento's earlier gialos like or jelly
if you want to be technical about it uh
like profondo Rosso but one of my
favorite ones which doesn't get brought
up a lot is the psychic or murder to the
tune of seven black notes uh which is a
Lucio fulchi movie dardana sashetti
wrote it he wrote a lot of um Lucio
fulchi's other films like the house by
the cemetery and stuff like that they
work together a lot
um but I was really into something about
that movie and I feel like I said nobody
talks about it really
um it's even when they're talking about
Lucio fulchi movies because everybody's
like all into his like Gore films which
is fair enough I like his Gore films too
but to be honest he made some giallo
movies
um you know like lizard and a woman's
skin and stuff like that which was okay
I didn't love that one but it was pretty
good but the psychic for some reason I'm
really really into that movie I really
like the conceit that at the beginning
of the movie you have a psychic
obviously who has a vision and it's all
like these disjointed like weird
unsettling images and I really liked
that the movie then played out in a way
that like you got to see each of these
disjointed images but like in context as
the movie went on but like it was always
like a surprising context you know what
I mean like you weren't expecting it to
go the ways the ways that it went or at
least I wasn't so I really liked the way
that was constructed like I was really
into that
um I was gonna say too what was another
one that I really liked oh house with
laughing Windows that's um poopy Avanti
he was the director I don't remember who
the screenwriter was on that but um I'm
really into that one too that's like a
really good giallo to see if you haven't
seen it it's kind of like a little bit
it's not as um what am I gonna say like
splashy
um it has some gore in it but it's
usually toward the end you know it's
toward the end but it's just so it's
kind of like a slow burn but I was like
really into it it was like really
atmospheric subjective Collective
perspective man you've been blowing the
chat up but we appreciate it you got a
lot of good comments that's okay man I
will talk about horror movies yeah you
must be are you a new um listener or the
first time you've actually talked in the
uh in the chat but it's good to have you
aboard I don't know if you're new or not
I think I've seen that name before
that's the first time I've seen it oh
and they said um oh this is also a great
one your Vice is a locked room and only
I have the key that's my favorite of all
time that is also a great one I'm really
into like I think I reviewed that not
too long ago did I not I'm pretty sure I
reviewed that because I went on a whole
stint where I was I think I did a whole
month where I just like reviewed Jello
movies it was yellow July like last year
so I did a bunch of those and I did some
um kind of more minor ones like I did
Sergio Martino's um the suspicious death
of a minor which
that's not a straight up shell it has
yellow elements but it's more like a
police procedural which you know
um and it had like some weird goofy like
comedy in it which I thought was kind of
strange I'm kind of into
I like the ones that kind of do
something a little bit different with it
too like I really liked all the colors
of the dark which was kind of like a
giallo movie but was also kind of like
Rosemary's Baby and also like kind of
had some like weird like surreal satanic
[__] going on like I was really into
that too because it was kind of doing
something different with the form and I
thought that was kind of neat but
Collective says yeah he's reasonably new
okay man okay it's good to have you
aboard where are you from man you in
America
Zach says I suggest a movie called Julia
and Julia it's a Jello starring Kathleen
Turner Gabriel Byrne and sting
and was the second movie shot on digital
video yeah I think I've seen that but it
might have been a long time ago yeah I
think it might have been a long time you
know a surprise you know I'll talk [__]
about sting trying to get people to
climb up on his link up in Shreveport
Louisiana that's okay yeah yeah
Louisiana yeah Shreveport he lived in
Louisiana for a while Louisiana not
Louisiana Louisiana
yeah I lived there for a while the um
I was gonna say about staying is
actually a very good actor a very
talented guy
[__] with him I'm into the police too
yeah
the police is [__] fantastic
uh that [__] Brimstone intraco was a
[__] great movie that he made yeah if
you haven't seen president yeah I mean
read the original play too which is by
Dennis Potter
um who is a great [__] waiter uh he
also wrote the singing detective and
Pennies from Heaven which are good but
uh brim Center treacle is great they
made a couple versions of it but we did
a review of this The Sting version which
I think came out in 1982.
because they did a version for British
TV also
yeah Collective I lived in uh
[__] right outside of Baton Rouge for
a while uh lived uh [__] past
Christian Mississippi I got all kinds of
cousins
who are Cajun I got Cajun cousins cute
too
I can hook you up with them though
they're all married gone now the [__]
well they didn't ask so yeah you're just
his little Cajun cousins and uh they
lived over in [__] uh Slidell right
outside Slidell
if you like jello films I'm wondering
how you felt about the movie the editor
which came out in 2014 I want to say it
was on shutter I don't know if it is
anymore it was like
it was almost like a parody but also
like an homage to gialo films and I
[__] loved it now I don't know if you
if you're not into giallo movies I don't
know if you'll
be into it or if you'll get it but me
and him watched it which one the editor
like a couple years back and I just oh
my God I [__] died which one was it
it was like a parody of a geology movie
do you remember yeah yeah yeah that was
[__] great it was so good it was so
good I saw that on it was on shutter
shutter yeah it was good it might be on
2B now I haven't checked for a while but
it's like I was really into it I thought
it was [__] hilarious but like I said
if you're not if you're not into geology
movies I don't know if you'll think it's
as cool or as funny as maybe I do a lot
of the uh Independent films that show up
on shutter and these little services are
[__] really good had they come out
back in the 80s who would have loved
them
a lot of it is just like spot on it's so
hard to keep up you know there's a lot
of them I try but it's hard there was
one that [__] this was years back me
and Jim reviewed it and I [__] loved
it and the uh the director [__]
thanked us for the review remember that
one which one do which one was that it
was the one where the people were
getting possessed by some kind of a
[__] thing it was
it was all acting no special effects it
was real cheap
it was real good and we gave it a really
good review and the director [__]
thanked us this is back when we were in
Sanford
[__] now I'm gonna have to like thank
you yeah I'm too drunk to come up with
it yeah director thanked us personally
that's so cool when that happened yeah
and like I said I feel so bad because
holy [__] man it's like look I love
horror I would watch horror 24 7 if I
had nothing else to do like if I didn't
have to have a job and all that other
kind of [__] but it's like it's so hard
because there's so many old movies that
I haven't seen too like holy [__] like
on my other channel like on scare salon
and [__] like that I was just writing
about
um doing like some 50s movies that I had
never got around to like night of the
Hunter and like uh curse of the demon or
Knight of the demon if you want to call
it that from 1957 I think that came out
so it's like I was trying to catch up on
like some old [__] that I should have
seen and hadn't seen up until now but
it's like there's all this new [__]
coming out and it's just like it's so
hard to like keep track look I just saw
I just saw the new Brandon Cronenberg I
just saw skinamarink I just saw like all
these new movies come out and I just
like want to see him and I just can't
keep up with all of it I wish I could
another one that comes to mind that was
new well I like turbo kid there's a
French flick and that [__] was yeah
that was good I like that I love turbo
kid uh I [__] love VFW which is like
a fake that was also great it was like
it was like it was like a carpet
Carpenter flick it was like same Assault
on Precinct 13. yeah yeah but
in their homage and Carpenter just in
every way yeah I want to see that one
again I like that one over the years
some of them have stuck with me other
ones I kind of forgot but
the one where the director [__]
thanked us that one I liked it I still
want to see that but again I just can't
remember what the [__] the name of that
thing was
they got some kind of sickness remember
and it would change
their personality and it did kill
somebody and would flip and it would
switch from one person to the next
oh [__] man what the [__] was the name
of this kind of like possession jumping
from one person to the next I know what
you're talking about and there was no
special effects in it but the acting was
good the story was [__] really cool
see if you have that you don't need it
yeah it was just the writing
honestly kill one person it would go
into the next one
it was something like that yeah I know
you're talking about oh probably
remember it yeah it had a good sense of
humor it was like an old it was like
like an old carpenter flick I'm trying
to think of like the movies that I've
seen recently it was a drug they were
taken oh that's right like a super crack
right oh [__] or a super meth yeah what
was the name of that I know what you're
talking about yeah what the [__] was the
name of that I'll think of it like 20.
it had a good humor and good horror if I
don't think about it then I'll yeah then
I'll think of it movies that I have seen
lately that have made a big impression
that I was really into and a lot of them
like I said if you like Jala movies like
some of these are not yellow movies
exactly but they're like kind of giallo
adjacent or they're inspired by Jello
movies one of my favorite movies that I
saw recently was in fabric
um which I guess is like polarizing
because it's like one of those weird
like Arty movies which I know a lot of
people don't like but I was super into
it I just like it's not a geology movie
but it's very like jello inspired like
the visuals and stuff and it's just it's
so weird like the
the elevator pitch for it would be like
oh it's about a haunted dress which
sounds dumb as hell but it's not
like that I mean you know what I mean
like see it it's good
um also another one I really liked
recently was uh another one that's kind
of giallo inspired was Barbarian Sound
Studio if you haven't seen that one
which is actually about a guy
who's doing uh like audio or like
voiceovers for a yellow movie like back
in the day like back in I can't remember
what year it was set in but it was set
in like the late 60s or early 70s and so
and that's really good too like I said
very slow burn very like
auditory and I was into that
um some other movies maybe not so gello
inspired but kind of just made a big
impression were sensor uh that's on Hulu
and that was about uh kind of the video
nasty Panic from the 1980s in the UK
um and it was about like a woman that
worked there like at the bbfc and um
that was really good and then there was
another one that's also on Hulu that was
called come true that I was really into
like about
um
it was kind of about like a sleep study
about like um the same
people having like the same nightmares I
guess that's about all I want to say
about that and it's kind of like surreal
but I was like really into that too that
was like really good so I always like
recommend like I said I always hesitate
to recommend horror movies because
everybody has their own subjective
tastes and you know stuff that like
really resonates with me I found that
like doesn't necessarily resonate with
other people so I'm always just kind of
like oh my God I loved this movie so
much and then they see it and they're
like what the [__] it's it's the wrong
with you you know what I mean but um
those are just movies that that I saw
fairly recently that really like stuck
with me you know what I mean
um subjective perspective sensory dog oh
that's good also I'm big into the video
nasties yeah me too like I said I'm not
British but I was married to a British
person for a long time and I used to go
back and forth to the UK from about the
mid mid 90s to like the mid-2000s
and so I was like really into British
culture I was really into seeing all the
video nasties and I was fascinated by
that whole
era because I remember you know I'm old
you know I grew up in the BHS era I was
born in 1972. so I remember
all of that kind of furor about
all of these movies being banned in the
UK or people getting arrested for having
copies of the driller killer and all
this other kind of stuff I was here so I
didn't even know about it well I was
here too but I did know about it I
didn't even know about it because I was
fast well I was fascinated by British
stuff like back then I was in a British
music I was in a British TV so I was in
all the like in the 80s so so it was
kind of like it's just crazy to me and
it's funny because I recently rewatched
the driller killer the able forever
movie
and um that was kind of one of the ones
and honestly like some people that were
around back then like said oh the
driller killer was the thing that kind
of like kicked off so like the whole
video nasties thing and it wasn't even
because of the content of the movie
necessarily because the Thriller killer
you think it's a slasher movie but it's
not really it's kind of more of a
psychological horror with some slight
slasher movie elements to it but um the
whole reason that the whole [__] got
kicked off was because of the [__]
poster or the [__] ad of the poster
that they ran like in a magazine that
had like a dude like you know drill into
the dude's head which was like a scene
from the movie where he goes around with
a drill and like drills in people's
heads like homeless dudes and stuff and
so they put that on the cover and I
guess it works because you know people
went to see the movie but
that was kind of the whole thing that
kicked off I don't know if that kicked
it off necessarily it might have
happened anyway but I feel like that was
kind of like the Catalyst you know what
I mean like everybody's seeing those
like oh my God we can't have this have
these ads like being in this magazine
where children can see it and stuff like
that even though it's like obviously
fake
uh Zach said possession I think is the
best video nasty movie that one's like
legit High art almost honestly like
possession
one I don't even know why that was even
on there because I mean I'm not saying
it's not [__] up because it is but
it's [__] up in a different way I kind
of feel like a lot of the stuff that's
on the video nasties list was just kind
of like cheat like you know cannibal
movies and [__] like that or slashers
possession is
aren't even notice I did like a long
like a long video about possession not
too long ago it's its own thing it's
definitely an art film
um and it's definitely one of the most
disturbing what the [__] things I've
ever seen also it's one of the most
it's it's a couple of the most Fearless
acting performances I've ever seen
Isabella Johnny and Sam Neal they just
[__] go for it in this one you know
what I mean Isabella Johnny I think had
like years and years of [__]
uh
I don't know if I'd call it PTSD after
doing this movie but um I wouldn't blame
her if she had had that because like the
[__] that she did in this movie is just
like
it's crazy this is a crazy [__] movie
it was out there
um and I still am not I've seen it a
couple times but it's like I'm not
entirely sure
that I understand was but again I don't
understand why it was on the video
nasty's list yeah there's some [__] up
[__] in there yeah there's yeah Isabella
Johnny [__] a tentacle monster but
there you know what I mean um but and
there's a lot of violence and blood and
stuff but it's like it's not
it's a whole it's a whole different
thing it's a whole different thing than
than say like cannibal ferrox you know
yeah which was not Carol I think well
Cannibal Holocaust is the one you're
probably thinking of there was a I saw
that dude [__] stick that sharp stick
to a quad of Monday I'm like nope nope
turn this [__] off we'll see that's what
I mean like look no I like Cannibal
Holocaust
um it's an important film it's it's
technically the first found footage film
if you want to be like that about it
pedantic about it
um so it is important in Horror history
and I think I think it is a good film in
its own right but I don't think you
can't defend
the animal cruelty and the animal
killing in there because there's no
reason they were just making a movie you
didn't really have to kill those animals
for real just to make a movie yeah just
to make a movie
um you know and yeah you could like
argue oh people ate it afterward
whatever it is still you were just
making a movie you cut off a turtle's
head on camera you killed the kawada
Mundy you you know it was [__] up it's
[__] up and honestly like I can watch
them kill people for fake in movies all
day [__] long and it doesn't bother
me I can kill animals I can shoot deer
[__] with [__] bows and [__]
good thing is I'm not sticking a sharp
stick through a little quadramundi that
you have in your hand and it's begging
no don't do that and you're not gonna
eat it that's what I mean that's you
know what I mean [__] rifle fires
damn near instant a good hunter that
[__] deer doesn't know what the [__]
hit it all right
I'm just not in it I don't agree with
trapping either it's just too much
stress on the animal nah
animals don't deserve that even though
you can say
the realist in me says well a lot of
these animals die by being eaten alive
by another animal sure but that doesn't
mean that's a safe for you to do it yes
that's just a justification because to
make you feel like less bad about it
when you have an animal eating another
animal alive at least they're trying to
survive the other animals trying to feed
its babies right
and you're sticking a damn stick through
a [__] hand no that's what I mean
you're a human that's not natural you
should know better yeah that's not
natural don't just use the excuse oh
well other animals do it oh and so
you're just saying you're no better than
another animal wouldn't even do that
right now then wouldn't stick a stick
through the damn quarter moon dude
what's going on they would [__] bite
it around the neck so shake it like that
[__] break his neck kill it
you know or sometimes I've seen some
weird [__] where a bunch of lions jump
on a zebra and one Lion's trying to
choke the zebra out
which is that they're just kind of
programmed to do that grabbing it by the
throat which that's not bad being
[__] choked out I've had dudes choke
me out during [__] wrestling matches
and [__]
but the thing is if you look closely the
other line that the [__] thigh is
already pulled a [__] whole bite out
of that damn zebra while that zebra was
still a lot was still awake
you know poor thing but that's that's
nature nature is [__] very cruel and
like that doesn't mean you have to be a
lion doesn't think about it but Eli's
not thinking about a human knows better
yeah right yeah Eli just goes I want
some of this oh it's still alive oh well
you know
I don't like that excuse that humans
give it's like oh well animals do it I'm
like well yeah but you should know
better yeah you should know about it
you're making a movie you don't need to
be [__] that's what I mean to be
honest like the older I get like I said
kill all the people you want fake in
horror movies I don't really care yeah
kill a cat or a dog we're gonna have a
problem even if like if it's fake if if
I don't like it like don't do that if
the animal falls into your custody you
as a human being really should try to
help it
yeah every time A bear walked up on me
I'm like What's Up bear how you doing
I'm trying to socialize and they run
you know [__] man I'm a job I wouldn't
even kill a [__] spider you know yeah
I'll be like you wanna you want you want
something to eat I got food
you can raid the fridge if you want
there's still coming to house they'll
open your refrigerator they're not dumb
I mean I made the mistake of feeding the
damn birds and they keep coming back
[__] papa papa [__] man one time get
in the house you give birth you give
sandhill cranes bread one time oh they
remember you they remember you and then
when they have babies they come bring
the baby they bring the baby and they
will knock
at your door with their beaks
they try to wait in the open and then
you open up and there's like a person
there's birds standing there look at
[__] four foot tall fight we had that
happen several times yeah [__] you doing
here where's I got the baby and they
just did yeah they got the baby they're
like the baby
they know exactly they're they're
surprised
yeah bread man give birds are smarter
than you think you're you it's a [__]
you're definitely not dumb [__]
seriously I have a book over there it's
called the mind of the Raven yeah and
it's by an ornithologist you raise
Ravens read that [__]
um you'll be amazed at how [__] smart
crows and ravens are they're smarter
than some people I know yeah seriously
it's it's pretty frightening it's not
frightening but it's uh enlightening for
sure
um but oh another thing I was gonna uh
what was that other movie that I was
gonna I just thought of it and I just
thought of it and then I just forgot
because he was saying like that was good
recommendations like like I said come
true that was one good one in fabric
that was another good one that I really
liked
um [__] I had another one that I was
gonna say
and somebody like something that
somebody mentioned like reminded me of
it
can't access happy birthday Tom who can
access oh thank you thank you bro yeah
his birthday's tomorrow like I said
tomorrow we're doing it today because we
already gave him presents and we already
had cake well we've got cake we gotta
shoot content tomorrow man come on yeah
Saturday is you can't be making porn
you're shooting porn day
well no I
mean birthday we got [__] we got to do
we can do birthday porn yeah we ought to
actually [__] stream
well I thought about that like well
here's the thing I'm not entirely sure I
guess we'll have to use this laptop yeah
in which history in which case yeah
um we're gonna have to unhook everything
because this is it's attached to this
which is attached to the wall and then
that's like so we're gonna have to move
everything I might be able to move the
whole desk and rotate the desk out
we'll figure it out tomorrow that would
probably be better because tomorrow
we'll figure out the logistics of the of
the other Studio because we're not gonna
shoot on this studio we got another
Direction it looks a lot cooler over
there yeah over there is like that's our
yeah I mean I can pick up the camera and
show you but it looks it looks like a
whole different room because we got
these [__] red
damn almost like funeral drapes and they
look cool as [__] I showed a porn buddy
[__] build that he goes oh man that
backdrop is [__] awesome it looks
satanic as crap to go yeah yeah I love
it that's gonna be what dude I got this
on Amazon for like 18 I'm gonna show
y'all
that's what we're talking about don't
give everybody motion sickness no I'm
not hold on we'll show them the the
valance as well yeah that's what we're
talking about the best part that's what
we're talking about and there's like
these weird [__] mirrors and stuff
there's like there's the shelf and all
the dildos and Lube yeah yeah
ha
so Jenny has to point out the dildos
well I'm just saying yeah somebody was
like Hey are those dildos
oh look look I sat down perfectly got
Spock lined up and everything well kind
of okay move it a little bit
not exactly don't get excited
there you go there you go
yeah John says happy birthday Tom my
future gift to you is I'll go to the
hockey motherland buy some land and
build a kick-ass Gothic Castle okay
above a small Hamlet on a hill and you
both can come and have it okay cool cool
we'll we'll shoot material
yeah okay yeah yeah we gotta shoot we'll
shoot content we gotta shoot well we
might go we might go eat tomorrow and
then we'll come back and yeah get ready
that's what we always do on Saturday
Saturday is kind of like our isn't that
funny like Saturday's our porn shooting
day yeah
not so much in the morning in the
morning we like run errands and stuff
but then in the afternoon we like we get
ready and like [__] shoot stuff uh
subjective perspective is talking about
man from Deep River that's right first
Italian cannibal film
uh it is really good I've seen it but I
haven't seen it for a very long time but
I saw it like a long time ago because
like I said I went through a thing where
I was trying to oh there's Pokemon she's
heavy and fat why are you getting so fat
don't call her fat yeah yeah you're
gonna [__] up yourself she doesn't know
what I'm saying yes she does she noticed
the answers why are you so fat you need
to go on a diet she's like [__] you
Daddy
I'm not fat she eats Without Limits well
that's our fault although manx is just
get fat
she's just round yeah it's all a ball
yeah yeah yeah if you guys know about
the um the what was the name yeah Coco
the gorilla that learned sign language
is very famous yeah he had a kitten it
was a she she had a yeah yeah and the
kitten's name was all ball and it was a
Manx and Pookie is also a Max yeah and
when you see when you when you say the
word all ball doesn't make sense until
you own them until you see a man and
then you're like oh yeah everything
that's why the gorilla named it all the
head is a round ball the [__] bellies
around ball the [__] and then they
have these tiny little short legs it's
all she's just round all little round
balls that's what she's talking about
and then they have that tiny little like
popsicle stick tail sticking out yeah
look that Wags look at her
yeah
she's laying on the ground all stretched
out with a Tailwind her little back legs
are like stretched out her little her
little drumsticks because they look like
little chicken legs yeah a little
chicken leg don't touch them though
because she has yeah
well she she has the thing where it's
like I'm gonna stick my feet out
like this like very obviously but if you
touch him because Tom is like I can't
resist and he just like goes in there
and she gets really mad
at my feet and she just like talks it's
almost like she wants you to touch her
feet but if you do she like gets really
upset
hahaha
you're hilarious you're a hilarious cat
uh yeah subjective perspective says
happy birthday Tom thank you very much
thank you very much
um John says I'll give you guys your own
Wing to shoot content in the castle just
for that okay I'll be up in the library
dress like been surprised
give you the camera bro
you're gonna be shooting it
well I don't know I don't want to put
anybody in that position if they don't
want to be in that position
you can't do that okay but yeah we'll
shoot some [__] tomorrow we'll see what
happens yeah
I'm gonna teach you some [__] for my
[__]
well I told you we need another well we
need another photo of like both of us
yeah for a streaming because at the
moment like streammates approved but
it's like the photo I have up there is
just me and it's a good photo yeah but
um I kind of feel like we should put one
okay we get that wig and [__] do and
we'll do we'll do a photo shoot me and
you yeah in the [__] selfie rig yeah
I don't think for the bio photo
because I'm not sure where they use that
yeah so I'm not really sure if you can
do nudity
no I don't I don't think you can you can
do like suggestions almost see here's
the thing about the photo you want I'm
almost thinking not to have me in it
because the customers really are not
there for me they're there for they're
there for you uh I'm more like a [__]
accessory uh so it'd probably be better
to just have you on that yeah but the
thing about it was that when I was
scrolling through them
all the other the couple a couple videos
they all had a photo of like yeah they
had like a sexy photo of like both of
them all right well we could have just
so like people would know it yeah more
than one and if you ever need to go solo
you could just change the photo out they
probably will if the photos approved
then you could probably rotate them
right I guess okay I don't know how long
it takes for them to approve them okay I
mean it's I I kind of feel like as long
as you're both approved because I have
the thing approved now it's like both of
our IDs have been uploaded they accepted
our photos and all that so it's like
they just want to make sure no one
underage is in there or anything
so the thing like my dashboard on there
now says like both of us are now allowed
to appear on camera so I imagine that
whatever we do it's like okay but I'm
not really sure okay but like I said I
have to look at their rules again
because I'm not entirely sure like
before we stream I need to know
what's allowed in the free section
because I don't want to do [__] that's
not allowed in there like yeah another
thing is are all
are all those weird ass dicks allowed
that's another thing I'm not entirely
sure because some of that's just not
human we'll see
and I know I think they're allowed I
know this is weird but like some
platforms even though they're not real
obviously but some platforms have a
problem with sex toys that look like
animals animals dicks you know what I
mean even though they're not real
because it's like too suggestive sorry
not all platforms do but it's like some
of them I know that some platforms do
ban
um you know some of those ones that look
like dog dicks or yeah or horse dicks or
whatever like they won't let you do that
I think streamate is okay with that
because we have seen some like people on
stream that used some of those or like
use the the horror sticks or whatever
but like I said they're not real so it's
not like obviously you can't really put
like bestiality around that or anything
but some of them don't even like the
whiff of that even if it's fake so you
really have to be careful that's the
thing about
one thing that I kind of like um
have been kind of like realizing
during the course of
getting ready to do this is that there's
really a lot you have to tiptoe around a
lot of stuff yeah she had to she had the
number 13 in her name they didn't like
that because yeah because I was trying
to tie it in with 13 o'clock because I
wanted to tie in with the larger
branding they were like that sounds
underage well they basically said well
you can't have a nickname on streammate
yeah that has a number in it that's
under 18. right whether it's a number or
whether it's spelled out because I tried
to spell it out and they're like yeah
you can't do that either and it's just
because they're like little beetles on
that yeah they don't want it's because
of pitos yeah yeah but you wouldn't
think of that unless you were like it
the number has to be over 18. okay yeah
like you can have a nickname that's like
that's like Jenny 19. yeah you can do
that but I was trying to do
13 cam which was like the name that we
were using for Twitter
and they're like yeah you can't do that
you can't have anything with a number in
it that's less than 18. because like I
said because of pennies you wouldn't
think of that yeah I didn't think of it
but then like when they said it I was
like oh yeah okay
I wasn't thinking of in terms of like
because I'm not a pedophile so I wasn't
thinking in those terms but I guess
that's where they like we can't have any
kind of like uh suggestion that anybody
would be searching for anything like
with that number and I was like well
[__] because I tried to explain I was
like look I was like we have a channel
like called 13 o'clock and I'm just
trying to tie it in with the larger
brand
um and they were like not having it so
but like like I said we I started
another Twitter and that's called 13. I
haven't put anything on it yet yet but
um that's just called 13 km but so I was
trying to call it the same thing on
streammate but they wouldn't let me
so I think I ended up having to call it
gen Tom cam or something yeah they
wouldn't let me call it a number oh well
what are you gonna do we don't have a
link tree yet you guys will know when
it's ready
yeah we're trying to get everything like
set up like I said I have the Twitter
everything's done yeah
and we have several weeks worth of I've
had like several dozen photos we have
like several several dozen several
hundreds yeah like well I mean not all
of them are like fantastic like you know
what I mean but I have like a lot of
photos we have like several videos [__]
like that I just I want every teaser
videos yeah I want everything to be like
ready before yeah sorry you know what I
mean yeah
all right so what time is it it's about
time to go
shut it down Jim all right so as I said
on Sunday we will be back talking about
the new Brandon Cronenberg film yeah
infinity pool which we watched last
night so we're gonna talk about that on
Sunday we talked about a little bit
today but we'll kind of go more in depth
on Sunday uh so I'm excited about it
because I was
I was really into this movie so so we'll
kind of like talk about another day but
yeah so have a good rest of your evening
you guys have a good day tomorrow and we
will see you guys again on Sunday
evening good night